[Música]
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a esta
especial de france 24 cerca de 25
millones de ciudadanos peruanos están
llamados a las urnas para elegir al
nuevo presidente de ese país tienen que
elegir entre dos candidatos que tienen
una concepción completamente diferente
del futuro que debe tomar perú para
hacer frente a la crisis económica la
crisis política ya la crisis social que
ha venido presentando en los últimos
años esta noche se espera un debate
presidencial televisado muy esperado por
los peruanos porque llevan a conocer
entonces las propuestas de estos dos
candidatos en torno a seis temas
principales que va a haber en esta
agenda de debate ellos van a estar
hablando de la crisis de la pandemia del
cob y 19 de la situación económica del
país corrupción generación de empleo
derechos humanos educación entre otros
temas que pueden llegar a esta mesa de
debate para poder conocer cuáles son las
propuestas que tienen estos dos
candidatos quiénes son estos candidatos
pues el nombre rápidamente por parte del
partido perú libre que representa a la
izquierda peruana
pedro o castillo que llegó
sorpresivamente a esta segunda vuelta y
representando a la derecha política
peruana está keiko fujimori del partido
fuerza popular que representa a unos
valores a los cuales pero tal vez ha
estado habituado en términos políticos y
también representa a la gran heredera
que dejó el ex presidente alberto
fujimori que gobernó perú desde 1990
hasta el año 2000 y que dejó el poder en
medio de controversia aún el día de hoy
el nombre de alberto fujimori sigue
causando divisiones opiniones y
contradicciones en torno a su desempeño
como presidente vamos a conectarnos con
nuestro corresponsal permanente allí en
la ciudad de lima francisco zacarías
para conocer detalles previos a este
debate muy buenas noches
francisco allí en la capital peruana y
cuéntenos qué es lo que se espera
entonces para la noche de hoy para este
debate presidencial
santiago muy buenas noches desde el perú
nos encontramos en la plaza de armas de
lima con el fondo del palacio
presidencial que será ocupado por pedro
castillo o keiko fujimori dependiendo de
los resultados de las elecciones del
domingo 6 de junio ambos se presentan a
este debate en medio de un empate
técnico según los últimos sondeos que
establecen una diferencia que es menor
al margen de error de las encuestadoras
justamente la compañía ipsos-apoyo
proyecta un 50 y 1.1 por ciento para
pedro castillo y un 48.9 por ciento para
keiko fujimori detallando un crecimiento
en la lideresa del fujimorismo la otro
sondeo de opinión fue realizado por la
encuestadora y ep que revelaba un
descenso de castillo y quien consigue el
40.3 por ciento del escrutinio de los
encuestados y mientras que keiko
fujimori llega a tener el 38.3 por
ciento en las elecciones
próximo 6 de junio van a ser muy reñidas
ambos candidatos van a pelear voto a
voto los resultados esta situación ha
puesto en perú en una polarización
los ciudadanos han resultado en
agresiones entre simpatizantes de ambas
candidaturas y justamente hay un sector
de o mejor dicho hay sectores de los
ciudadanos que no están de acuerdo con
castillo ni de acuerdo con fujimori
pues francisco vamos a conectarnos
gracias por este reporte desde la ciudad
de lima ya nos pone un poco más en
contexto cómo están las cifras y las
previsiones de cara a estos comicios del
próximo domingo y nos conectamos ya con
la señal que nos llega en directo acá la
redacción de france 24 de lo que está
sucediendo allí en la capital peruana
comienza este debate presidencial entre
keiko fujimori y pedro castillo beatz
debido a la pandemia de lakovic 19 como
en los demás debates realizados por el
jurado nacional de elecciones este
evento cumple con todos los protocolos
de bioseguridad y normativas aprobados
por el comité de salud y seguridad en el
trabajo del jurado nacional de
elecciones del mismo modo recordar que
este debate tiene con finalidad que la
ciudadanía contraste las propuestas de
gobierno de cada partido político
buscando con ello la emisión de un voto
informado y programático
respecto a la dinámica o metodología del
debate a continuación un vídeo para
poder comprender mejor esta bienvenidos
al debate presidencial de la segunda
elección 2021 el debate cuenta con la
participación de los candidatos
presidenciales correspondientes a los
dos partidos políticos que pasaron a la
segunda fase de la elección presidencial
adicionalmente se contará con la
participación de 10 ciudadanos y
ciudadanas que formularán preguntas a
los candidatos
el debate se dividirá en seis bloques
cada uno de estos con una temática
específica bloque 1 el perú del
bicentenario bloque 2 salud y manejo de
la pandemia bloque 3 economía y
promoción del empleo bloque 4 educación
ciencia e innovación bloque 5 lucha
contra la corrupción e integridad
pública
y derechos humanos políticas sociales y
atención a poblaciones en situación de
vulnerabilidad el bloque 1 tendrá un
formato de transmisión del tema y cada
candidato tendrá dos minutos para
desarrollarlo
[Música]
del bloque 2 al bloque 6 tendrá un
formato semi estructurado con
intervenciones de diálogo abierto con
preguntas de la ciudadanía y se
compondrá de la siguiente manera primera
parte cada candidato tendrá tres minutos
para la presentación de sus propuestas y
planteamientos
segunda parte
los dos candidatos mantendrán un diálogo
abierto en donde cada uno tendrá cuatro
minutos de participación la
administración del tiempo dependerá de
cada uno
tercera parte un primer ciudadano
ciudadana tendrá 30 segundos para
formular una pregunta a los dos
candidatos en donde cada uno tendrá un
minuto y medio para responder luego un
segundo ciudadanos ciudadanas tendrá 30
segundos para formular una pregunta a
los dos candidatos en donde cada uno
tendrá un minuto y medio para responder
cuarta parte finalmente cada candidato
contará con un minuto para transmitir su
mensaje de cierre y para garantizar la
equidad de trato y la transparencia el
orden de participación de los candidatos
se determinó por un sorteo realizado el
18 de mayo ante un notario público y en
presencia de los representantes de cada
partido político los candidatos deberán
participar en el debate conteniendo las
buenas prácticas la tolerancia y el
respeto libre de agresiones y opiniones
que atentan contra la dignidad del
candidato contrario
estamos todas y todos invitados a ser
testigos y celebrar este debate de gran
importancia para el perú
en cuanto a las reglas del debate es
importante precisar a ambos candidatos
que las reglas del debate se fundamentan
en los principios del derecho a la
competencia política libertad de
expresión tolerancia política e igualdad
por lo que invocamos el respeto de las
mismas cualquier interrupción o agravio
por parte de los técnicos representantes
no será permitido como ya es conocido
por ustedes está prohibido que los
candidatos de ambos partidos políticos
realicen cualquier tipo de entrega o
intercambio de objetos durante el debate
se recuerda que según lo acordado por
los partidos políticos los moderadores
tenemos la facultad de establecer el
orden en el caso de que alguno de los
participantes interrumpa y exprese
agravios o insultos sin mayor preámbulo
vamos a dar pase entonces al primer
bloque temático de esta noche
antes de iniciar hemos preparado un
vídeo sobre el tema a tratar los
invitamos a verlo
[Aplausos]
bloque 1 el perú del bicentenario cuando
nacimos como república se presentó el
desafío de conformar una base de
ciudadanos con derechos y la facultad
para autogobernarnos estos son los hitos
más importantes luego de 200 años de una
república en construcción y 12
constituciones la primera constitución
de 1823 reconocía a la ciudadanía a los
hombres casados o mayores de 25 años
alfabetos propietarios o profesionales
en la constitución de 1839 la ciudadanía
se extendió a los hombres mestizos e
indígenas analfabetos en 1908 se dio la
ley que permitía el ingreso de las
mujeres a la universidad y en 1919 se
decretó la jornada de 8 horas como
medida general para los trabajadores en
1920 se da la primera ley de
reconocimiento de comunidades indígenas
en 1950
se les reconoce a las mujeres su
condición de ciudadanas
independientemente de su estado civil y
en 1979 que el sufragio es universal sin
condiciones de instrucción educativa o
sexo en el 2005 se aprueba la ley que
habilita el voto a policías y militares
y en el 2020 se aprueba la ley de
paridad y alternancia de género
todos estos hitos ocurrieron en un
contexto de constante
gobiernos electos y mucha inestabilidad
política sobre todo en las primeras
décadas de la república así desde 1816
hemos tenido 59 años y 36 presidentes de
gobiernos producto de golpes de estado
136 años y 30 presidentes de gobiernos
electos en procesos electorales o
transiciones institucionales al 2021 nos
encontramos en el período más largo de
continuidad de gobiernos electos de
nuestra historia
damos pase a la primera parte de este
bloque que trata sobre el perú del
bicentenario en esta primera parte ambos
candidatos contarán con dos minutos para
su exposición siendo así damos pase
entonces de acuerdo con el orden
previamente establecido al candidato
pedro castillo de perú libre tiene usted
dos minutos para su exposición adelante
buenas noches compatriotas buenos noches
perú buenas noches arequipa buenas
noches señores moderadores señora
fujimori buenas noches
en primer lugar gracias a dios por
traerme hasta acá y gracias por haberme
permitido llegar a este escenario llegar
a esta altura políticamente gracias a
miles de compatriotas que nos han
acompañado en diferentes pueblos en
diferentes
caminar es vengo desde puña soy maestro
delante de la escuela olvidada
he compartido con mis alumnos muchos
años 24 años de servicio he compartido
con mi ronderos mi servicio con cuidando
la salud cuidando la salud social de mi
pueblo
vengo de este espacio del magisterio
nacional preocupado por la educación
vengo con las manos limpias
vengo a decirles que soy un hombre de
trabajo un hombre de fe un hombre de
esperanza me formado trabajando todo el
tiempo de mi vida yo sé lo que es rascar
una olla para compartir algo y darle
alimento a mis hijos para dar alimento a
mis alumnos
yo sé barrer una escuela donde no hay un
personal de servicio yo sé cómo es que
tenemos que cautelar como tenemos que
cuidar lo que se suda
nosotros los del campo nosotros lo
adelante sabemos muy bien que el mejor
abono de la tierra es el sudor del
hombre
mentira es lo que dicen que vamos a
cerrar tu bodega que te vamos a quitar
el pan que te vamos a cerrar la puerta
que vamos a quitar tu casa vamos a
quitar tu propiedad los que trabajamos
si sabemos cómo se cautela tu propiedad
mi propiedad nuestra propiedad será
cautelar no más pobres en un país rico
palabra de maestro
gracias candidato pedro castillo de perú
libre ahora escucharemos por dos minutos
a la candidata keiko fujimori de fuerza
popular adelante candidata
muy buenas noches arequipa buenas noches
perú buenas noches señor pedro castillo
hoy es el día más importante de este
proceso electoral después de muchas
excusas finalmente estamos acá para que
usted pueda contrastar y comparar las
ideas y planes de gobierno de ambos
candidatos
pero lamentablemente tengo que empezar
mi exposición en este debate rechazando
categóricamente los sucesos de violencia
que ocurrieron el día de ayer
usted señor pedro castillo con su
lenguaje y sus mensajes de odio de
división de luchas de clase no solamente
ha generado las agresiones contra
periodistas sino el día de ayer contra
ciudadanos que libremente salieron a
expresar su opinión
usted está acostumbrado a tirar piedras
esta es una de las piedras que tiraron a
nuestra caravana y que le rompió la
cabeza a una simpatizante nuestro
yo hoy vengo a dar propuestas
propuestas para sacar adelante nuestro
país en medio de esta terrible crisis
sanitaria y económica
sueño con un perú donde preservamos la
paz y no se promueve la violencia
donde se distribuya riqueza y no pobreza
donde se puede los ahorros de los
trabajadores y no se les confisquen
donde se fortalezcan las instituciones y
no se las cierre donde se ayude a los
más necesitados
y no se les manipula
hoy vengo a proponer un cambio sí un
cambio con esperanza un cambio hacia
adelante
agradeciendo a ambos candidatos hacemos
una pausa comercial y regresamos con el
segundo bloque salud y manejo de la
pandemia en el debate presidencial de
segunda vuelta 2021
pues es el primer bloque de este debate
presidencial en perú el primer tema de
esta noche es el perú del bicentenario
también sirvió como una especie de
presentación de lo que van a hablar los
candidatos a lo largo de este debate y
lo que traen como propuestas para
presentarse para presentarlas a los
ciudadanos peruanos que están muy
atentos a esta señal de la televisión
pública peruana con la cual hemos hecho
enlace para poderles transmitir a
ustedes este debate presidencial
rápidamente antes de dar paso al
análisis en rápido este tema número uno
castillo hablo de su carrera como
maestro de sus orígenes humildes en la
zona andina de perú dijo ser un
candidato con las manos limpias y negó
que se vaya a violentar digámoslo así la
propiedad privada que es algo que se le
ha criticado se le ha señalado por ser
un candidato de izquierda por su parte
fujimori rechazó la violencia del día
anterior en donde según dijo con una
piedra
y lograron alcanzar y atacar a una de
sus simpatizantes dijo no a la violencia
y dijo que viene con propuestas para
distribuir la riqueza fortalecer las
instituciones y dar un cambio de
esperanza y un cambio hacia adelante
hacia el futuro de perú voy a entonces
con los invitados que tenemos para para
esta noche pasó a presentarse los está
con nosotros mauricio sabaleta él es
politólogo escritor y columnista del
diario 'el comercio' es autor de varios
libros allí en perú se conecta hasta
ahora desde la ciudad de charlotte en el
estado de carolina del norte en eeuu
mauricio buenas noches gracias por estar
con nosotros y bueno primeras
impresiones de esta primera intervención
muy corta sólo dos minutos para cada uno
de los candidatos en su opinión
hola santiago muchas gracias por la
invitación a mí lo que me ha llamado la
atención es que los dos han entrado
rápidamente a la táctil pedro castillo
se ha presentado como un maestro pero
primero dijo los que trabajamos hay un
hay una podemos decirlo se le ha dicho a
la candidata fujimori de cuál es su
fuente de trabajo es algo recurrente en
todas las postulaciones él comienza con
eso y además comienza respondiendo algo
que la propia candidata le había
endilgado al candidato castillo que era
usted le va a quitar las bodegas a las
pequeñas tiendas no a la persona
corriente y en realidad le ha dicho
claramente desde un inicio eso es falso
nosotros no vamos a quitar la bodega
nadie vamos a defender la propiedad y
eso es algo interesante porque el
programa de pedro castillo al menos el
programa original es muy estatista y
está dando al menos alguna seguridad
para un votante más en el centro que se
encuentra entre estos dos candidatos en
los extremos y por el lado de keiko
fujimori bueno rápidamente ella condena
la violencia en relación a la lamentable
masacre
experimentamos el día domingo y luego
hace una referencia directa a el ataque
que lamentablemente sufrieron en su
caravana y garitas y entonces lo que
está tratando de hacer es decir que este
candidato es un candidato
antidemocrático y violentista
rápidamente en el guerra él también es
bueno analista de opinión pública
marketing político y marketing e
investigador de mercado está conectadas
de la ciudad de lima su opinión
rápidamente señores bien antes de dar
paso nuevamente al debate
hola si me escuchan bien soy perfecto en
su adelante
sí bueno
y va a marcar una tendencia de un antes
y un después frente a las declaraciones
que han dado cada uno de los candidatos
va a marcar una diferencia de una reñida
pelea y unity batalla que han tenido y
van a tener además la oportunidad de
pelear o de luchar contra los diversos
medios
que además se han infundado dentro de
todo este contexto de la campaña los
temores por un lado que hay frente a la
candidatura de keiko fujimori que fue la
candidata desde primera vuelta que más
ha tenido que enfrentar y afrontar y por
otro lado de pedro castillo a quien
evidentemente le han atribuido otros
temores y que terminan haciendo una una
diferencia bastante compleja en el
desarrollo de su propia campaña en sus
gracias por este primer panorama
regresamos al lema la señal de la
televisión pública peruana ya ha
comenzado a perdonar la ciudad de
arequipa en el sur del país
allí ya comienza el debate del segundo
tema que es la salud pública y el manejo
de la crisis sanitaria desatada por la
pandemia el cover 19 escuchados y
personas con comorbilidades sin embargo
otros países de la región han priorizado
a trabajadores con funciones esenciales
como docentes pilotos entre otros
[Música]
ahora sí en esta primera parte del
bloque ambos candidatos tienen tres
minutos para exponer sobre la temática
planteada salud y manejo de la pandemia
así como damos inicio la candidata keiko
fujimori de fuerza popular para su
exposición adelante candidata
esta pandemia ha enlutado a miles de
familias en nuestro país ha destruido la
salud la economía y la esperanza
sin duda también se debe a las malas
decisiones a la indiferencia y a la
incapacidad de los diferentes gobiernos
que en los últimos años no hicieron nada
por mejorar la salud de nuestro país
quiero empezar mis primeras palabras
expresando mi profunda gratitud y
reconocimiento a todo el personal de
salud a los médicos a las enfermeras a
los técnicos al personal administrativo
que día a día exponen su vida para
cuidarnos
quiero ratificar porque así lo hemos
conversado con diferentes dirigentes que
se van a evaluar aumento de sus
remuneraciones y por supuesto
comprometernos a pagar la deuda que el
estado tiene con ustedes más de 500
millones de soles después de todo el
esfuerzo y el sacrificio que ustedes
vienen haciendo esto es inaceptable
la estrategia para enfrentar esta
pandemia tiene varios pilares en primer
lugar dejaremos de tener una venda en
los ojos y eso significa descartar las
pruebas rápidas esas pruebas que no nos
permitía saber la verdad que no nos
permitía saber quiénes eran los
contagiados y utilizaremos 70.000
pruebas moleculares por día para poder
saber quiénes son las personas que
necesitan apoyo hacer una política de
rastreo y brindarles toda el apoyo que
ellos necesitan en segundo lugar es
inaceptable que tantos peruanos hayan
fallecido por falta de oxígeno hemos
anunciado la construcción de 100 plantas
de oxígeno a nivel nacional y
entregaremos más de 10000 concentradoras
en las zonas más alejadas de nuestro
país
sobre la vacunación saludamos que el
presidente sagasti haya anunciado la
adquisición de 60 millones de dosis de
vacunas esto es una buena noticia sería
importante saber el cronograma de
llegada de estas vacunas y por supuesto
que nosotros nos comprometemos a hacer
el proceso de vacunación este año
rápidamente para que todos los peruanos
sean vacunados y para lograr este
objetivo hemos convocado al señor carlos
neuhaus que demostró gran capacidad de
gestión en los juegos panamericanos
haremos que la vacunación se haga cerca
a tu casa en cada farmacia en las
iglesias en los colegios para que todos
los peruanos seamos vacunados este año
gracias candidata keiko fujimori de
fuerza popular ahora damos base al
candidato pedro castillo de perú libre
perú libre quien también cuenta con tres
minutos para su exposición sobre salud y
manejo de la pandemia adelante candidato
castillo pueblo peruano
para nosotros la salud no este problema
de la pandemia no solamente es un
problema sanitario es un problema
estructural es un problema histórico no
es un problema solamente de dolor es un
problema de crisis generalizada hace
mucho tiempo acaso antes de la pandemia
a los hospitales no estás en la pandemia
los hospitales no estaban colapsados
acaso antes de la pandemia miles de
compatriotas no formaban colas en los
hospitales acaso antes de la pandemia no
habían niños con plomo en la sangre y
siguen habiendo ahora grandes problemas
de salud acaso no hay personas
vulnerables que aparte de la pandemia
no hay alguien quien le lleve un pan a
la boca pero esto hoy en día esta
pandemia ha desnudado la precariedad de
este edifico rupo estado ante su pueblo
pero esto tiene culpables directos
el fujimorismo con 10 años de gobierno
y consecuentemente con mayorías
parlamentarias
nunca agendaron a la educada a la salud
como derecho constitucional y ahora
traen un ramillete de propuestas como
papá noel tenemos que entender que la
salud es una tarea de todos
abracemos esta causa queremos entender
que la salud tiene que ser un derecho el
oxígeno que tiene que ser un derecho no
un negocio cuánto costó una mascarilla
en plena pandemia cuánto costó un balón
de oxígeno en plena pandemia cuando ha
costado una pastilla en plena pandemia
donde estaba el congreso donde estaban
las grandes mayorías donde estaban los
que dicen que son sensibles por el
pueblo donde estaban los líderes
políticos tradicionales políticos que
hoy en día salen a la palestra más de
120 mil personas fallecidas sentadas en
el país eso tenemos que no solamente
solidarizarnos sino ser una cruzada
nacional y para eso gracias a los
expertos gracias a los compatriotas que
se han sumado a esta tarea para hacer
una sola causa vacunaremos a todos los
peruanos
y no vamos a permitir que ningún peruano
mayor de 18 años se quede sin vacunar
hasta el 31 de diciembre vamos a hacer
que la ciencia tecnología y la
tecnología no no no trunque y diga y que
vengan a decir que las vacunas tienen
agua o que la saliva es un desinfectante
lo que tenemos que hacer es que la
vacuna sea o sea de garantía para todos
los peruanos vamos a implementar la el
primer nivel de atención mejor a los
centros de salud que están abandonados
cinco mil brigadas de salud
los kits por la vida como derecho
constitucional vamos a hacer que el
médico vaya a buscar el enfermo no el
enfermo busque al nuevo en busca del
enfermo el estado tiene que acercarse a
la población no la población vaya a
mendigar y forme grandes colas en los
hospitales y pida auxilio palabra de
maestro
gracias candidato pedro castillo de perú
libre culminado esta primera parte ahora
pasamos al momento del diálogo en donde
ambos candidatos tendrán cuatro minutos
que podrán administrarlos como lo deseen
es importante mencionar que tanto la
candidata como el candidato cuentan con
un profesional que estará a cargo de sus
cronómetros e intervenciones asimismo se
le pide a los candidatos alzar la mano
para solicitar la palabra yo estaré
atento a ello a fin de procurar un
diálogo fluido pero ordenado alguno de
ustedes dos desea iniciar con la
participación muy bien empezamos con la
candidata keiko fujimori de fuerza
popular adelante candidata
parece que el señor pedro castillo no
sabe que el fujimorismo fue gobierno
hace 30 años y culminó hace 20 años y
parece que no sabe cómo funciona el
estado porque el poder legislativo no
puede construir hospitales eso lo hace
el poder ejecutivo pero si quiere hablar
de gestión parece que le ha dado amnesia
me gustaría que usted le pregunta al
presidente de su partido al señor
cerrone al que se denomina el médico del
pueblo cuánto de los hospitales que
inició en la región de junín se
culminaron
la respuesta es cero
ninguna de las obras siendo el
presidente regional
se terminaron
es inaceptable que tantos ciudadanos
en las diferentes provincias de junín a
quienes he visitado y les he preguntado
abiertamente que hizo el señor cerró la
respuesta sea nada pero no estamos aquí
solamente para criticar estamos acá para
lanzar propuestas y no piedras
a nosotros nos preocupa mucho la
atención primaria porque ésta se cerró
indebidamente considero por elpresidente
vizcarra tenemos que ampliar nuevamente
aperturar las postas médicas
modernizarlas y esto va a permitir que
los grandes centros médicos no estén
tugurizados dentro de todas las
enfermedades que lamentablemente se han
dejado de lado me preocupa sobre todo el
cáncer que está centralizado en la
capital para ello anunciamos que vamos a
construir tres grandes centros
oncológicos uno en el norte y otro en el
centro y otro en el sur de nuestro país
le parece candidatas y para fomentar el
diálogo entre aguas o fases candidatos
le damos base al candidato pedro
castillo de perú libre para que también
pueda exponer parte de sus propuestas
encantadas
adelante candidato pedro que muchas
gracias creemos importante que hay que
implementar mil camas uci con la
finalidad de también de que los cuidados
intermedios con cánulas de alto flujo y
concentradores de oxígeno pero quien va
a encaminar este problema de la salud si
no son nuestros trabajadores que han
sido olvidados también en sus
reivindicaciones han muerto médicos en
plena pandemia es decir los héroes los
que tienen que ver con la salud se ha
abandonado a ese personal en todas las
costas del perú tenemos que implementar
equiparla las brigadas tiene que este
tiene que ser un trabajo de equipo con
las autoridades las fuerzas armadas los
compatriotas los grandes profesionales
yo llamo al perú a no dar tregua a esta
pandemia no podemos permitir más que una
persona llegue a camas uci
porque si llega a camas o si es
garantizar que regrese en su bolsa negra
candidatos qué les parece si hablamos
acerca al sistema nacional de salud
consideran importante una reforma de
este sistema si es así qué cambios
realizarían alguno de los dos desea
iniciar
en este caso levantó la mano el
candidato pedro castillo y le damos paso
adelante candidato
el sistema nacional de salud hace tiempo
está precarizado
cuando alguien se enferma o se enfermaba
antes de la pandemia
tiene que todavía buscar una situación
burocrática para que llegue al lugar
donde corresponde es necesario
universalizar el sistema de salud a
nivel nacional y por eso en nuestro
gobierno la salud no será un privilegio
tampoco será un cachuelo no será un
negocio será una prioridad para que el
paciente ingrese inmediatamente a
cualquier establecimiento y es más hay
que acercar que cada médico atienda
en cada sector en cada en cada zona
inmediatamente a la polar acerquemos el
estado acerquemos el médico a la familia
candidata keiko fujimori también usted
puede exponer su respuesta ante esta
pregunta si yo considero que es
fundamental concluir los hospitales que
se quedaron inconclusos por diferentes
gobiernos regionales sobre todo de
izquierda que no han demostrado
capacidad de gestión se necesitan por lo
menos 80 a nivel nacional pero si tienen
que además implementar con la tecnología
que permitan tener las historias
clínicas electrónicas de tal manera que
se pueda compartir la información a
nivel nacional y utilizar también la
telemedicina hoy la tecnología permite
que los médicos puedan atender a
diferentes pacientes no importa donde
ellos se encuentren pero hay algo
fundamental que es el acceso a los
medicamentos los hospitales estándar
desabastecidos y lo que es peor muchas
veces los medicamentos se descartan por
que expiraron lo que falta es un manejo
logístico de los medicamentos
nosotros nos vamos a encargar que
ninguna posta médica en ningún hospital
se quede desabastecido de los
medicamentos que tú necesitas
para recordar a todas las personas que
siguen este debate y presidencial al
candidato pedro castillo de perú libre
le quedan dos minutos con seis segundos
y a la candidata keiko fujimori de
fuerza popular le queda 51 segundos les
parece candidatos si hablamos acerca de
la atención de otras enfermedades
durante la pandemia el gobierno ha
centrado su esfuerzo en combatirla pero
ha descuidado otras enfermedades que
también son importante atender las que
propondrían para solucionar esto
y el candidato pedro castillo adelante
el problema de la salud como servicio
que está bajo esta constitución ha sido
totalmente desatendida nosotros no
solamente miramos la pandemia miramos
los graves problemas que tiene el
interior del país porque no un hospital
materno-infantil en cada región para
terminar con la mortalidad materna y
aquellos niños que mueren al nacer
porque no una prioridad desde la escuela
acercar a cada familia cuántos miles de
niños con problemas bucales con
problemas que tienen problemas de visión
problemas de desnutrición donde estén en
el estado donde esté el gobierno el
problema de la salud es un problema
transversal que hay que atenderla y dar
dotarle de presupuesto pero que no
llegue solamente al funcionario que no
llegue el dinero que se destine desde el
de lima y llegue una migaja a las
regiones tenemos que movilizar y hacer
participar a todas las organizaciones
del pueblo el pueblo tiene que estar
organizado para atender este es este
derecho constitucional
gracias candidato castillo candidata
fujimori su turno si yo he hablado hace
un momento del cáncer y la construcción
de tres grandes hospitales a nivel
nacional
hace algunos días hemos visto cómo se
vacunaban a personas que tienen
enfermedades raras y se necesita un
centro especializado también para
atender a estos pacientes sabemos que la
salud mental ha sido muy afectada sobre
todo en época de pandemia tenemos que
ponerle especial énfasis pero yo he
escuchado al candidato pedro castillo
que va a intentar vacunar a todos los
peruanos este año nosotros tenemos al
señor carlos neuhaus que nos ha trazado
una ruta de cómo hacerlo yo le
preguntaría cómo lo piensa implementar
cuántas vacunas al día piensa hacerlo en
donde nos pero nos quisiéramos saber
gracias candidata keiko fujimori
candidato castillo puede iniciar gracias
a las puertas abiertas de varios países
que se han comprometido no solamente con
la vacuna sino implementar que el perú
no solamente puede estar esperando una
pandemia para que recién se bese se
preocupe por la salud del
es necesario implementar el ministerio
de ciencia tecnología e investigación
para que las personas comprometidas en
esto y los grandes profesionales
nuestros compañeros compatriotas
peruanos que expertos también que han
ido fuera de este país regresen con esa
tecnología con ese con él con esa
experiencia para gestar la propia la
trate la propia tecnología nuestra no
podemos mendigar derechos
constitucionales y es más más allá de
ver cómo vamos a hacer la pandemia es
necesario la emergencia alimentaria
puede llevar la vacuna ahora a la
población pero está con el estómago
vacío esa será nuestra prioridad
gracias al candidato pedro castillo para
recordar a ambos candidatos y también a
la población que sigue atentamente este
debate a la candidata keiko fujimori de
fuerza popular le queda 8 segundos
mientras que al candidato pedro castillo
de perú libre le resta 10 segundos
algunos de ustedes quisiera enviar un
mensaje final si adelante y candidata
keiko fujimori si bueno el señor pedro
casi o no quiso contestar mi pregunta yo
responderé rápidamente nosotros
vacunaremos 160.000 peruanos por día y
lograremos gracias candidata keiko
fujimori candidato pedro castillo desea
hacer uso de sus 10 segundos si no más
casas con los trabajadores de salud y
otros y otras agresiones iniciasen
laboralmente hay que reconocer la labor
fundamental de él se tiene que respetar
el derecho al trabajo
muchas gracias a ambos candidatos ahora
iniciaremos la tercera etapa de este
bloque con las preguntas ciudadanas
sobre salud y manejo de la pandemia cabe
precisar que las preguntas que serán
formuladas han sido elegidas por un
comité conformado por el jurado nacional
de elecciones y las instituciones
aliadas que permiten realizar este
debate a través de la campaña pregúntale
a tu candidato mediante la plataforma
voto informado ahora sí sin más
escuchemos la primera pregunta
[Aplausos]
buenas noches mi nombre es jorge aguirre
y soy de la ciudad de lima me gustaría
hacerles la siguiente pregunta la
pandemia de mostrado el precario estado
de nuestro sistema de salud pública no
solo a nivel de infraestructura sino
también en cuestión de capacidad de
personal y prevención por eso en un
eventual gobierno suyo como potenciará
la red primaria de atención de las
postas y los hospitales regionales con
fe recursos y si usted considera la
empresa privada como un aliado
[Aplausos]
bien de acuerdo con el orden de
intervención cada candidato tendrá un
minuto y medio para responder
damos fase para su respuesta al
candidato pedro castillo de perú libre
adelante a ser candidato muchas gracias
bienvenida la inversión privada para ver
también la salud tenemos importante que
el sector privado tiene que contribuir
de alguna u otra forma pero lo que
tenemos que hacer es que el estado hoy
en día gasta e invierte en la salud
cuando el paciente ya está con la
enfermedad cuando ya tienes un cáncer
terminal el estado tiene que hacer uno
tiene que detectar a tiempo la
enfermedad porque no razona duro
magnético en cada centro de salud para
detectar a tiempo las enfermedades los
compatriotas y a partir de ahí
estructurar qué enfermedades tienen
tiene nuestro tiene nuestro los peruanos
y acercar al estado para que a través de
las postas con profesionales capacitados
permanentes enfermeras cuerpo médico y
equipamiento tienen que estar
inmediatamente con un no solamente una
ambulancia sino tiene que ver una
prevención
inmediata a través en este mundo
digitalizado para que la persona la
autoridad vea inmediatamente qué
problemas tienen cada comunidad en cada
centro poblado en cada rincón del país
le quedan 24 segundos candidato castillo
si desea puede continuar
gracias creemos importante que eso pasa
también por la situación de que los los
funcionarios del estado tiene que
destinar los presupuestos sin actos de
corrupción en cualquier espacio en casa
así es el el espacio más pequeño del
último rincón del país no se puede casar
con la educación perdón con la salud no
puede ser un privilegio tampoco una
discriminación
gracias candidato pedro castillo de perú
libre ahora le corresponde a la
candidata keiko fujimori de fuerza
popular responder la pregunta de este
ciudadano también cuenta con un minuto
con 30 segundos adelante candidata keiko
fujimori
jorge le agradezco por su pregunta
efectivamente la atención primaria es
increíble y lamentablemente fue anulada
por una decisión equivocada del
presidente de vizcarra ésta tiene que
ser reapertura da pero se ha hecho una
pregunta sobre la convocatoria del
sector privado y me parece muy
pertinente porque también de manera
absurda se le negó la posibilidad del
sector privado que ayudará inicialmente
en la construcción de plantas de oxígeno
y eso tiene que cambiar en el medio de
esta pandemia todos los peruanos tenemos
que estar unidos y se convocará a las
iglesias se convocará a los gobiernos
regionales a las municipalidades a las
universidades y por supuesto a la
empresa privada que quiera colaborar
para construir plantas de oxígeno para
el proceso de vacunación para quienes
quieran ayudar en la reapertura de la
atención primaria pero voy a aprovechar
esta oportunidad también para mencionar
sobre el tema del caso
ha dicho y contrincante el señor pedro
castillo desde la bancada de fuerza
popular nosotros apoyamos desde el
congreso para la eliminación del caso
lamentablemente el gobierno y el poder
ejecutivo observaron nuestra norma pero
todas las personas del sector salud del
caso saben perfectamente cuál es nuestra
posición
muchas gracias candidata fujimori a
continuación presentamos la segunda
pregunta ciudadana
[Aplausos]
buenas noches mi nombre es segundo tiene
esperanza a ver mejor escobedo y soy de
la ciudad de virú me gustaría hacerles
la siguiente pregunta la pandemia ha
generado caos y problemas a la salud
como estrés depresión ansiedad y duelo 5
incluso que han enlutado a muchas
familias que no se encontraban
preparadas para dicha situación en este
sentido que estrategias de salud mental
piensan fomentar durante su gobierno y
como las harán viables gracias
[Aplausos]
para dar respuesta a esta pregunta el
turno de intervención se ha invertido e
iniciamos entonces con la respuesta de
la candidata keiko fujimori de fuerza
popular adelante es una candidata
según dina efectivamente como lo dije
hace algunos instantes la pandemia ha
afectado muchísimo la salud mental
nosotros proponemos la apertura de
nuevos espacios y centros comunitarios
en alianza con diferentes
municipalidades ampliaremos atenciones
también en los diferentes centros de
salud somos muy conscientes que esto
sobre todo ha afectado a niños y jóvenes
que necesitan de un apoyo profesional y
no los vamos a dejar solos este minuto
que me queda quiero expresar mi profundo
pesar aquí nos han perdido un familiar
por el kobe 19 y para ellos hemos
lanzado una propuesta que yo sé que no
les va a devolver a su ser querido pero
para ellos anunciamos con oxígeno se les
entregará 10.000 soles a cada familia
que ha perdido de un ser querido por la
incapacidad de los últimos gobiernos
podido manejar esta pandemia sabemos que
esto no le devolverá a su familiar pero
por lo menos tendrán ustedes un apoyo
por parte del estado desde acá les
expresamos nuestro profundo pesar y toda
nuestra solidaridad gracias tiene
todavía 13 segundos candidata fujimori
tal vez desea enviar algún mensaje a la
población
y decirles que vamos a trabajar
fuertemente para lograr vencer esta
pandemia
los peruanos unidos sé que lo vamos a
lograr
gracias candidata keiko fujimori de
fuerza popular ahora corresponde al
candidato pedro castillo de perú libre
también por un minuto y 30 segundos
brindar la respuesta a la ciudadana
adelante candidato pedro castillo el
estado no solamente debe acercarse
económicamente a la familia
el estado tiene que estar
permanentemente al lado de la familia
dentro y fuera del hogar
más que todos los niños el perú no
solamente tiene espacios específicos
vulnerables el perú hace tiempo está en
cuidados intensivos
hay niños que observan
como muere como muere su hermano como
muere su padre como grita la familia y
hay que hacer una cruzada nacional
haciendo el llamado a los profesionales
como los psicólogos a las personas que
tienen que encaminar para superar toda
ese problema psicológico mental que
tiene porque si no tratamos eso y vamos
a hacer que solamente piensen en el
dinero vamos a tener personas
más allá de recuperar y contribuir con
su familia recupere socialmente
tenemos que entender que hizo un estado
promotor de la salud un estado promotor
de su alimentación de la educación en
diferentes etapas de la vida en
diferentes etapas de la de la juventud
madres frustradas padres frustrados
jóvenes frustrados eso tenemos que
combatirla
muchas gracias candidato pedro castillo
muy bien agradecemos a ambos candidatos
por sus respuestas ahora daremos pase a
las palabras de cierre del bloque salud
y manejo de la pandemia y el tiempo para
ello es un minuto para cada candidato
damos inicio con las palabras de cierre
con el candidato pedro castillo de perú
libre adelante el señor candidato
creemos importante de que la salud
no tiene que mirar en los momentos
inmediatos
tenemos que ver la vulnerabilidad de la
población no solamente por la pandemia
hacer un mapa de riesgos y hacer un
sinceramiento al país cuántas personas
murieron por kobe la mayoría de personas
cuando un pueblo un estado no está
preparado más muere por temor
haremos un mapeo haremos un seguimiento
pueblo por pueblo y haremos una
convocatoria una cruzada nacional no
solamente para controlar al joven no
solamente para ver esta pandemia sino
para ver los graves problemas
estructurales de la salud y hago un
llamado a todos los expertos para que el
gobierno no solamente nos convoque y lo
reconozca económicamente sino que en
cada región con las autoridades con los
gobiernos regionales asumamos
responsablemente este derecho
gracias candidato pedro castillo de perú
libre de la misma forma la candidata
keiko fujimori de fuerza popular cuenta
también con un minuto para enviar un
mensaje final acerca de este tema salud
y manejo de la pandemia adelante de
candidata keiko fujimori
nuestros enfermos no se curan con
comunismo
el cob it no se detiene con la lucha de
clases
la pandemia no se combate con piedras
hoy quiero comentar una frase que nos
dejó el papa juan pablo segundo y que lo
tuve muy presente
en los 16 meses que estuve injustamente
a prisión no tengan miedo
y cuando salí de prisión por tercera vez
comprendí que yo tenía que transmitir
esta frase que me acompañó no tengas
miedo porque vamos a controlar la
pandemia no tengas miedo porque no voy a
permitir que los peruanos sigan muriendo
por falta de oxígeno o camas uci
no tengas miedo porque todos los
peruanos
seremos vacunados este año queridos
compatriotas no tengan miedo
gracias candidata keiko fujimori hacemos
una pausa comercial y regresamos con el
tercer bloque de esta noche que tratará
sobre economía y promoción del empleo
finalizó así entonces el segundo bloque
salud y manejo de la pandemia de kobe 19
diferentes perspectivas y diferentes
puntos de vista en cuanto a la condición
en la que se encontraba la salud peruana
antes del inicio de la pandemia
coinciden los dos candidatos en
fortalecer la red hospitalaria en
fortalecer la salud a nivel regional más
allá de lima la capital pero en
diferentes posturas en cuanto al manejo
de la pandemia de kobe 19 y cómo ampliar
la capacidad de vacunación y darle más
rapidez al plan de vacunación ya vamos a
profundizar en este tema con nuestros
invitados antes de darle paso al
análisis quiero ponerlos en contexto
sobre la situación política en la que se
encuentra pero un país completamente
polarizado de cara a estas elecciones
presidenciales veamos el informe
nueve presidentes en 21 años la muestra
de una convulsa realidad política en
perú en noviembre de 2002 eventos
ocurrían en tokio y lima de manera casi
paralela mientras el entonces presidente
alberto fujimori renunciaba el congreso
lo destituía argumentando actos de
corrupción e incapacidad moral
permanente
[Música]
y por la patria tras la salida de
fujimori el presidente del congreso o
valentín paniagua asumió de manera
interina como mandatario unos meses
después el opositor alejandro toledo
ganó las elecciones
pero durante su mandato el país quedó
paralizado por semanas de huelgas en
diciembre de 2003 toledo exigió la
renuncia de todos sus ministros para
desactivar un escándalo de tráfico de
influencias que involucraba a su primera
ministra beatriz merino
a toledo lo sucedería en julio de 2006
el ex presidente alan garcía pero tras
dos años al mando su gabinete tuvo que
renunciar para impedir la aprobación de
un voto de censura en el congreso por
recibir pagos a cambio de concesiones a
la compañía noruega discover petroleum
en junio de 2011 el militar retirado de
izquierda ollanta humala ganó por un
estrecho margen a la hija del ex
presidente alberto fujimori keiko y se
convirtió así en el primer gobernante
izquierdista en perú en 36 años el 2016
keiko fujimori perdió de nuevo unas
elecciones presidenciales esta vez ante
el ex banquero de wall street- pedro
pablo kuczynski
pese a la derrota a su partido consiguió
una amplia mayoría en el congreso la
legislatura terminó con la renuncia de
kuczynski por posibles acuerdos con los
fujimoristas para indultar al ex
presidente tras ello llegó martín
vizcarra en septiembre de 2019 vizcarra
disolvió el congreso y en octubre keiko
fujimori fue enviada a prisión
preventiva 2020 sería el año de los
juicios políticos en septiembre el
congreso aprobó una moción para
destituir a vizcarra por presuntos
contratos irregulares con un cantante
pero poco después de salir airoso
comenzó el proceso de noviembre donde
finalmente se aprobó su destitución tras
ello fue investido manuel merino que
duró sólo cinco días en el cargo en
medio de intensas protestas desatadas
tras una moción de censura vizcarra que
parte de la población entendió como
fraudulenta la propia onu afirmó que la
policía había hecho un uso excesivo de
la fuerza el 17 de noviembre sería
investido francisco sagasti y tercer
presidente de perú en una semana y
último hasta las pasadas elecciones de
abril
keiko fujimori o pedro castillo serán
los décimos presidentes de perú en 21
años tras una segunda vuelta que
mantiene profundamente dividido al país
bueno pues ya lo ven ustedes una
sociedad completamente dividida en
cuanto al futuro que debe tomar este
país suramericano para hacer frente a
esa crisis política desatada desde hace
varios años que ha llevado a cuatro
mandatarios a estar por periodos muy
cortos a ser destituidos por el congreso
y también que a origen a marchas por
parte de los ciudadanos en las calles
exigiendo un cambio en la política del
país continuamos entonces con la
transmisión en vivo en directo desde la
ciudad de arequipa en donde tiene lugar
este debate presidencial en perú
escuchemos
[Música]
pasemos a ver más información sobre este
tema
bloque 3 economía y promoción del empleo
entre 2009 y 2019 la tasa de empleo
informal solo disminuyó de 77.2 por
ciento al 70 y 2.7 por ciento es así que
en promedio siete de cada diez peruanos
de la población económicamente activa
ocupada tienen un empleo informal sin
embargo en el 2020 a causa del cobi 19
la tasa aumentó al 75 punto 3% es decir
11 millones 356 mil peruanos tiene
actualmente un empleo informal en la
última década los gobiernos regionales
que ejecutaron en promedio el 68.3 por
ciento de su presupuesto destinado a
inversión financiera obras de
adquisición de bienes la mayor tasa de
ejecución se presentó en 2015 con un
81.7 por ciento y la menor tasa de
ejecución fue en el 2018 con un 55 punto
8 por ciento
recordemos que cada representante tiene
tres minutos para exponer sobre el tema
en esta parte inicial damos inicio
entonces con la candidata keiko fujimori
de fuerza popular adelante es una
candidata
esta pandemia no solamente se ha llevado
la vida de miles de peruanos sino que ha
destruido nuestra economía y ha
destruido millones de puestos de trabajo
el sector más afectado son los
emprendedores y la micro pequeña empresa
para ellos tenemos una serie de
iniciativas en primer lugar tenemos que
cambiar el chip de cómo funciona el
estado no tenemos que perseguir la
informalidad
tenemos que construir formalidad
basta ya de esas dobles sanciones que
cierran tu local y te pone en tu multa
por favor tenemos que darles
capacitaciones acompañarlos en su
crecimiento y por eso hemos dicho
licencia cero al momento de nacer no vas
a pagar los cobros que te piden las
municipalidades o los ministerios dos
años tributación cero para que el
momento que estás creciendo puedas
hacerlo con total libertad
hemos anunciado un crédito especial
volver a empezar en el que vamos a dar
hasta 10 mil soles a un millón de micro
y pequeños emprendedores 5 años de
gracia recién al partir del quinto año
empezarás a pagar este préstamo pero
también tenemos que generar empleos y
para eso hemos dicho haremos miles de
obras por supuesto te extrañaremos los
grandes proyectos aquí en arequipa majes
siguas 2 en cusco donde acabo de estar
el hospital lorena para puno
agua y desagüe para puno y juliaca las
grandes ciudades en piura el proyecto
alto piura
chavimóchic en la libertad chinecas en
ancash agua para ica las carreteras
centrales de penetración por supuesto
que ampliaremos la principal
la interconectividad que necesita a
iquitos el puerto de pucallpa entre
otras entre otras muchas obras que vamos
a hacer pero un proyecto que ha sido muy
bien recibido frente a la incapacidad de
los gobiernos regionales sobre todo de
izquierda hemos dicho que hay
presupuestos que no se están usando el
presupuesto del canon hay millones de
soles disponibles hemos anunciado canon
para el pueblo 40 por ciento del canon
irá dirigido directamente a las familias
que más lo necesitan en esas zonas
extractivas en esas zonas de pobreza en
esas zonas donde el estado y tus
autoridades se olvidaron de ti canon
para ti
gracias candidata keiko fujimori de
fuerza popular ahora es el turno del
candidato pedro castillo de perú libre
el también cuenta con tres minutos para
su exposición adelante candidato muchas
gracias
quisiera mostrar los titulares de dos
periódicos en el mismo día
y miente y quién dice la verdad
nosotros no vamos a quitarles sus
ahorros
a la gente que trabaja
respetaremos la propiedad privada no más
abusos de las afp y las ongs los
trabajadores son los dueños de sus
ahorros
vamos a impulsar una economía popular
con un mercado
el mercado no puede controlar al estado
es el estado el que tiene que controlar
a la población los mercados
en ese marco queremos importar no vamos
a permitir que la inflación golpee a la
mesa del pueblo
y trabajaremos de la mano con las
empresas vamos a crear el valor agregado
bienvenido el empleo es necesario y es
urgente
que el marco en el plazo de un año
lograr un millón de empleos pero empleos
de verdad
vamos a impulsar créditos a los micros y
pequeños empresarios
comprándoles sus deudas a aquellas
personas que hoy en día están en su
sobre económica y aquellos
transportistas que también tuvieron la
posibilidad de salir en plena pandemia y
les cogió por ahí en mal momento o una
sanción en forma sorpresiva tiene que
ser condonada vamos a conversar
teléfonica vamos a conversar con las
empresas de luz eléctrica para que se se
baje su recibo de luz se condone no
puede haber darle bonos pero al final
tienes un recibo abusivo por pago de por
pago del servicio tenemos que empezar a
implementar la infraestructura vial no
pueden estar pudriéndose los productos
en el centro paul en las comunidades y
las carreteras hecho un desastre donde
esté el estado vamos a destrabar y vamos
a ir vamos a implementar la inversión
pública para destrabar los proyectos el
año pasado muchísimos proyectos las
municipalidades en los gobiernos
regionales es momento de aperturar esas
obras y exigir a la zona que cobre las
grandes deudas a las empresas que deben
al estado y exigir a la zona también
para que dé posibilidad de facilidades a
formalizar a estos hombres emprendedores
con la finalidad de que no solamente
emprenda sino que el estado esté
presente dándole facilidades económicas
administrativas y legales
tenemos que asumir una responsabilidad
con la juventud
jóvenes 100.000 empleos este año mismo
gracias candidato ahora culmina esta
primera parte esta primera aproximación
al tema pasamos al momento del diálogo
sobre economía y promoción del empleo
nos encontramos en un momento difícil
desde el punto de vista de la economía y
promoción del empleo la pandemia está
dejando consecuencias graves siendo el
mercado laboral el foco de afectación la
pérdida de puestos de trabajo reducción
de los ingresos y alta informalidad los
ciudadanos esperan propuestas concretas
viables y sostenibles de ustedes los
están escuchando y estamos a una semana
de las elecciones en esta parte cada
candidato tendrá cuatro minutos para
intervenir que deberá administrar de la
mejor manera
recuerden que pueden pedir la palabra
levantando la mano o en el micrófono
quien se anima a empezar
señora keiko fujimori adelante
quiero dirigirme
todos los emprendedores el sector
gastronómico que tiene un restaurante
y que se han visto afectados más de
100.000 pequeños negocios tuvieron que
cerrar más de un millón de personas
tuvieron que perder su trabajo para
ellos proponemos perú abierto hemos
dicho que vamos a cambiar los protocolos
y las normas vamos a reducir el horario
desde el toque de queda de tal manera
que ustedes puedan atender no solamente
a la hora de almuerzo sino también en la
noche
de esta manera ustedes tendrán más
clientes pero es importante también
permitir utilizar los espacios abiertos
los patios las veredas cómo se utilizan
en otros países de esa manera los vamos
a acompañar en este proceso de volver a
empezar
candidato pedro castillo gracias creemos
importante que no se puede implementar
la reactivación de la economía y generar
empleo si no logramos con una no
logramos la vacunación a toda la
población vacunados los maestros y
también impulsando la vacunación para
los niños se abrirán las escuelas al
abrir las escuelas se abriera la tienda
se abrirá el mercado se abrirán los
restaurantes se abrirán los espacios
pero también es necesario que el estado
recupere la riqueza
la riqueza que tiene el país en ese
contexto vamos a recuperar la riqueza
como la renegociación de los contratos
con las grandes empresas con las
empresas mineras que se llevan la
riqueza del país recuperar el gas de
camisea para darle a todos los peruanos
recuperar el petróleo como es posible
que en un país tan rico haya tanta
miseria haya tanta desigualdad y
solamente se lucren los grandes y se
coman el pan incluso personas que nunca
trabajan
creemos importante
y el trabajo genera riqueza
entonces los que sabemos trabajar
tenemos que llevar adelante las personas
emprendedoras el perú es un país de
emprendedores permítanos hacer una
pregunta para continuar esta dinámica
como evalúa en la gestión respecto a la
recaudación de impuestos han considerado
realizar cambios y de ser así cuáles
serían los principales aspectos que se
tendrían que considerar quién se anima a
dar la respuesta candidata fujimori
balance y antes de contestar su pregunta
ya que el señor pedro castillo ha
hablado del pan yo creo que es
importante hacerle algunas preguntas ya
que cuando estuvimos en su
propuesta fue cerrar las importaciones
les digo queridos amigos si se cierran
las importaciones de manera inmediata el
precio del trigo va a volar y el precio
del pan que ahora pagas en promedio 20
céntimos va a pasar a costar un sol 60
esto es de manera inmediata las
propuestas del señor castillo afectarán
directamente tu bolsillo sobre la
pregunta de la recaudación de impuestos
nosotros lo que planteamos es antzar la
base conseguir que mayores empresas
contribuyan en esta recaudación de
impuestos y esto se logra con confianza
con reglas claras hablando cuáles son
nuestras propuestas no con medias
verdades o con propuestas trasnochadas
de cerrar las importaciones
muchas gracias candidata fujimori
candidato castillo es que sabemos
trabajar tenemos que ser hablar con la
verdad
no estamos hablando de que vamos a
prohibir las importaciones pero vamos a
proteger al productor nacional hoy es el
día de la papa
y sin embargo se está trayendo papas y
otros lugares y porque tienes el gestor
quien el king el boom de la papa que se
vienen de otros lugares
como es posible que la papa se pudra en
los centros poblados y no se le impulse
el desarrollo de nuestros propios
agricultores de nuestros propios
emprendedores
en ese sentido bienvenida a la inversión
privada pero con reglas claras que no
abusen de los trabajadores y nuestra
prioridad son los hombres de abajo vamos
a un impulsar una economía de abajo
hacia arriba la igualdad de
oportunidades no de arriba hacia abajo
no pensando en el bolsillo de los de
arriba sino en el hambre de los de abajo
candidata fujimori si yo quisiera enviar
un mensaje también a nuestros hermanos
agricultores hemos anunciado un programa
minería para el agro
vamos a cobrar una contribución
adicional a esas grandes empresas
mineras que hoy tienen más utilidades
pero ellos se van a encargar de
financiar los reservorios los canales de
irrigación que nuestros hermanos
agricultores necesitan además
inyectaremos mil millones de soles
agrobanco para que puedan darte los
préstamos que estás esperando llevaremos
semillas llevaremos fertilizantes más
baratos crearemos un fondo de firme y
decomisó justamente para bajar ese
precio y como antes por supuesto
llevaremos los tractores directamente al
campo permítanos insertar una temática
para generar la dinámica en estos
minutos que en este tiempo que todavía
queda de este bloque cuáles serían de
ser ustedes eventualmente gobierno las
políticas que generen productividad para
que esta economía se reactivó y después
de la pandemia a corto mediano y largo
plazo 15 animadas responder
candidato castillo adelante creemos
importante que hay que pensar en los
hombres que ponen en que preparan la hoy
en el país los que pone los manteles en
el país la agricultura está totalmente
abandonada
usted puede tener una buena cosecha pero
las carreteras están en pésimas
condiciones es necesario que los hombres
que te garantizan desayuno almuerzo y
cena todos los días se estén en la
primera línea para nosotros nos importa
aunque sea un agricultor y no esperar
una oportunidad política decir que no me
importa miro a 100 mil o diez mil
personas chinecas y va hay que empezar
con estos proyectos en el norte en el
centro en el sur hay que empezar a
reactivar la economía
impulsar el desarrollo dando no
solamente herramientas un banco de
semillas en cada provincia
hay que generar de qué manera el
agricultor se siente convencido de que
el estado si se acerca
a las personas abrir los espacios de los
mercados inmediatamente y darles
seguridad combatiendo también la
delincuencia y el abuso
candidata keiko fujimori si quiero
también dirigirme al sector turismo un
sector fundamental aquí en arequipa en
el cusco
donde ya no llegan los turistas
hemos dicho que vamos a declarar en
emergencia este sector se priorizarán la
llegada de las vacunas para ellos para
que nuevamente nuestro país sea un
destino fundamental
les otorgaremos tres años de cero
impuestos en sus actividades de esta
manera vamos a apoyarlos de manera
directa pero quiero también hablar de
los hermanos trabajadores vamos a
defender sus derechos es una fiel tiene
que actuar mucho más proactivamente pero
también vamos a aumentar el sueldo
mínimo no se dejen llevar por esas
especulaciones o mentiras que dicen los
señores de perú libre bien les
recordamos que de los cuatro minutos la
señora keiko fujimori tiene nueve
segundos y el señor pedro castillo tiene
32 segundos los invitamos a ambos a
redondear sus ideas para culminar este
bloque quien quien es el candidato
castillo
queremos importante hacer una verdadera
descentralización del país sea
descentralizado lóbulo burocrático
administrativo porque no descentralizar
de una forma rigurosa
el ministerio de economía para que los
gobernadores regionales dejen de hacer
cola en el ministerio en el ministerio
de economía como los alcaldes hay que
hacer un llamado a los hermanos
pescadores hay que abrir los espacios en
cada uno de las zonas para abrir los
grandes proyectos que hoy en día
nuestros gobiernos regionales y los
alcaldes han empezar
muchas gracias señora keiko fujimori le
quedan nueve segundos de utilizarlos
adelante como dijo el señor carranza en
el debate anterior vamos a cuidar tu
salud tu comida y tu trabajo
gracias hemos escuchado las propuestas
de ambos candidatos pero llega el
momento de escuchar a nuestra ciudadanía
[Música]
buenas noches mi nombre es coronel y
para y soy de la ciudad de lima me
gustaría estar en la siguiente pregunta
en el marco de un cambio en el tipo de
economía extractiva que ha venido tenido
nuestro país qué medida plantea para
industrializar algunos sectores con el
fin de empezar a añadir valor agregado a
nuestras materias primas apuntando todo
un desarrollo tecnológico y a la
generación de empleo
y
hay que recordar que cada candidato
tendrá un minuto y medio para responder
y damos pase primero para su respuesta
al candidato pedro castillo de perú
libre adelante señor candidato si muchas
gracias el estado tiene que estar cerca
no solamente para generar empleo para
generar trabajo sino también acordarse
de los jóvenes y en ese entender creemos
importante de que hay que llamar a todas
a todos los expertos como los ingenieros
agrónomos para construir las grandes
cuencas hidrográficas para sostener en
el tiempo estos grandes proyectos y
generar empleo para que también sea
sostenible como la conciencia de agua
como en implementar que estos
profesionales
tenga no solamente en lima sino también
en el marco en todas las regiones un
trabajo descentralizado con expertos en
el transporte en experto en construir
hospitales experto en construir escuelas
los medios de comunicación y ser
fiscalizado en tiempo real desde el
gobierno central
tienes todavía a 31 segundos candidato
castillo
muy bien entonces damos pase a la
candidata keiko fujimori de fuerza
popular para que responda a esta
consulta de este ciudadano ella también
cuenta con un minuto con 30 segundos
adelante candidata keiko fujimori
jorge la industria extractiva en nuestro
país es un motor fundamental de nuestra
economía y sabiendo que los precios de
los metales van a subir a nivel
internacional por eso hemos planteado
dos propuestas fundamentales minería
para el agro para que a través de una
contribución adicional un aporte
solidario estas empresas puedan
financiar la construcción de reservorios
y canales de irrigación para nuestros
hermanos agricultores pero sabiendo
también que hay muchísima pobreza y que
miles de familias se han visto afectadas
en el medio de esta pandemia hemos
lanzado la propuesta canon para el
pueblo 40 por ciento de los presupuestos
serán dirigidos directamente a las
familias aprovecho este tiempo adicional
que me queda para dirigir un mensaje a
los hermanos transportistas a ellos que
hicieron un paro nacional y que nadie
los escuchó con ellos me ha reunido en
reiteradas oportunidades vamos a
analizar e investigar por qué el precio
del combustible del perú es el más alto
de la región y hemos anunciado que vamos
a reducir el impuesto selectivo
para poder bajar el precio el
combustible y esto además bajará
inmediatamente los precios de los
alimentos vamos a hacer una
reorganización de la sutran y por
supuesto que las multas en épocas de
pandemia no las que sean por atropello
pero esas multas abusivas las vamos a
eliminar
muchas gracias candidata fujimori ahora
escucharemos la siguiente pregunta a
ciudadana
[Música]
buenas noches mi nombre es karim ali son
pérez segovia soy de puno y mi pregunta
es la siguiente ya sabemos que el
turismo es una gran cadena que
desarrolla la economía en nuestro país
sin embargo a raíz de la pandemia el
ingreso no sólo de hoteles restaurantes
artesanos entre otros
pero aún asustados drásticamente más que
todo en aquellos lugares donde esta es
la base de su economía que propone usted
para reactivar este sector que fue
olvidado en los últimos años
i
[Música]
nuevamente la intervención se ha
invertido iniciamos entonces con la
respuesta de la candidata keiko fujimori
de fuerza popular adelante sin la
candidata
karen
tú que estás en puno efectivamente el
sector turismo como lo dije hace algunos
instantes se ha visto terriblemente
afectado pero es importante saber que
por ejemplo la mayor cantidad de
turistas que vienen a nuestro país
provienen de países como los eeuu donde
la vacunación ya superó los niveles del
60 por ciento ellos están listos para
venir lo que hace falta es que nuestro
país se adapte y prepare la llegada de
turistas por eso he señalado claramente
que la vacunación tiene que priorizarse
justamente en este sector para que todos
los turistas del extranjero puedan venir
con seguridad y puedan venir a invertir
y a gastar en nuestro país
quiero aprovechar estos 41 segundos que
me quedan para dar mi mensaje a los
hermanos pescadores sabemos que lo que
ustedes necesitan es una reorganización
de todo el mar necesitan un apoyo
directo en el proceso de formalización
me han pedido nuevamente la creación
del ministerio de pesquería para que se
sientan escuchados cosa que no ha
ocurrido en los últimos años haremos los
desembarcaderos que lamentablemente
están abandonados queridos amigos
pescadores gracias por su apoyo y por su
confianza
gracias candidata keiko fujimori ahora
es el turno del candidato pedro castillo
para responder la pregunta de esta
ciudadana adelante cantidad muchas
gracias creemos importante que el
turismo no solamente tiene que hacerse
con fines de lucro sino tiene que
impulsarse desde la escuela desde el
colegio que nuestros niños conozcan la
realidad que nuestros niños sepan en
donde el entorno el entorno de su
comunidad de su provincia de su región y
valoren lo que tenemos que valorar el
idioma hay que valorar los climas pero
tiene que ser realidad
nosotros sabemos
sabemos que para tenerlas para sacar
correas hay que tener el cuero
pero entendido está de que por ejemplo
cuando se impulse el turismo un ejemplo
claro te resulta más barato un vuelo
aéreo de lima cusco que del cusco a
machu picchu por eso es necesario
revisar esos contratos con esas empresas
abusivas y aquellos de aquellas empresas
que hoy en día sus impulsores que de la
pseudodemocracia se llama públicamente a
la muerte entonces creemos importante
manifestar de que el turismo es interno
y externo pero hay que darle todas las
facilidades
gracias a es candidato pedro castillo
agradecemos a ambos candidatos por sus
respuestas a nuestros ciudadanos y ahora
daremos pase a las palabras de cierre
por un minuto
a continuación entonces comenzamos con
el candidato pedro castillo de perú
libre adelante señor candidato no
creemos importante que el perú que es
inmensamente rico no solamente para
atender los pescadores a los
agricultores a los maestros a los de
salud el problema de pandemia sino que
hay que entender que hay que recuperar
devuelva mole al país su soberanía
económica política social recuperando
las grandes riquezas que tiene el país
que se han alquilado por tiempo y han
permitido el saqueo por años y que se ha
mantenido viejos políticos corruptos y
mafiosos en ese entender creemos
importante que el perú tiene que ser
para los peruanos no traigo ramilletes
de promesas les traigo este valor de
lucha que he aprendido en la calle que
aprendió como luchador como rondero como
trabajador que sí que sé si sabes y sé
cómo se hacen las cosas no más pobres en
un país rico
gracias candidato pero al castillo de
perú libre de la misma forma la
candidata keiko fujimori de fuerza
popular cuenta con un minuto para un
mensaje final adelante candidata
el señor pedro castillo solamente hace
referencia a los hombres el hombre para
la olla un poquito más de respeto con
las mujeres que somos muchas en nuestro
país que trabajamos y yo por eso hoy
quiero dirigirme a ustedes mujeres de
mamá a mamá
somos nosotras las que vamos a definir
esta elección yo sé que muchas de
ustedes
dirigen la economía de su hogar son
ustedes las que se encargan de criar a
sus hijos de sacar adelante a sus
familias les pido que no pierdan la fe
sé que son muchas las que están
preocupadas pero yo me voy a encargar no
solo de recuperar la economía nacional
sino de recuperar tu economía familiar y
de ayudarte a darle mejores
oportunidades a nuestros hijos para que
sean felices te lo digo de mamá a mamá
palabra de mujer agradecemos a la
candidata keiko fujimori
ha llegado el final de este bloque
hacemos una pausa comercial y regresamos
con el cuarto bloque que tratará de otro
tema muy importante como el es el de la
educación ciencia e innovación
retornamos
tercer tema de este debate presidencial
en perú la economía y la promoción del
empleo el empleo informal en este país a
raíz de la pandemia de cobain 19
aumentado al 75 por ciento de acuerdo a
las cifras oficiales rápidamente
fujimori destacó un plan de tributación
cero y de créditos para volver a
comenzar en la parte económica para
aquellas empresas afectadas por la
pandemia y también habló sobre la
importancia de impulsar los proyectos de
grandes infraestructuras en todo el
territorio peruano castillo reiteró su
intención de respetar a la propiedad
privada a respetar los fondos de ahorros
de los ciudadanos y también destacó que
quiere hacer una economía popular con
mercado para generar en un primer año de
gobierno un millón de empleos ambos
destacaron créditos para las pymes y
también para compras de deudas
y fujimori destacó la necesidad de
impulsar la industria turística de perú
a través de una rápida vacunación para
que puedan llegar turistas extranjeros
por su parte el castillo el candidato de
perú libre habló sobre la economía está
activa y también sobre la minería los
diferentes planes que intentará
establecer allí también partiendo de un
punto muy importante y central de su
campaña que es la educación de los
jóvenes en las zonas rurales fue a
darles unos datos sobre la economía de
perú para dar paso al análisis con
nuestros invitados en uno de los retos
importantes que va a tener el nuevo
presidente de perú será recuperar la
senda de ese crecimiento económico que
ha tenido el país después de la pandemia
del cobi 19 que ha dejado ya más 2
millones de personas contagiadas y cerca
de 70 mil muertos en 2020 la economía
peruana se desplomó un 11.2 por ciento
un resultado con el que el país
interrumpió 22 años consecutivos de
crecimiento y también registró la peor
caída en las últimas tres décadas en ese
país suramericano el desempleo se
duplicó hasta el 13 por ciento principal
en lima que es el gran centro urbano de
este país al tiempo que los salarios se
redujeron en más del 25 por ciento según
los datos oficiales entre tanto la
pobreza que es un problema en américa
latina' que antes equivalía al 20.2 por
ciento de la población al cierre del año
del primer año de la pandemia se ubicó
en el 30.1 por ciento es decir más de 10
millones de peruanos viven con menos de
3.2 dólares al mes estos son reportes
que ha preparado las redacciones de
france 24 pasó entonces a conversar con
mauricio sabaleta en la ciudad de
charlotte en carolina del norte sobre su
análisis de estos dos bloques sobre todo
el tema económico muy importante muy
tenso por la situación que está viviendo
el país o análisis mauricio
bueno en realidad lo que a mí me ha
llamado la atención de ambos candidatos
es la falta de capacidad para darnos
mayores detalles cómo van cómo van a
implementar estos planes en el caso
particular de keiko por timón yo respeto
estas entregas de beneficios bonos está
hablando un 40 por ciento de la entrega
del icann a un minero es las regalías
generadas por la minería en el caso del
castillo acaso la falta de programa sea
más estás moza no de hecho cuando la
candidata fujimori le pregunto cómo es
que ustedes van a asegurar la vacunación
para todos los peruanos hacia el 31 de
diciembre de este año termina
respondiendo sobre la creación de un
ministerio de ciencia y tecnología
entonces creo que los dos candidatos dan
uno
generalidades
y en realidad lo que propone castillo me
estoy refiriendo a él expresamente no es
un sentimiento en contra de quienes han
manejado el estado en los últimos años y
en el caso de keiko fujimori lo que ella
está dando es acaso con mayor
inteligencia estratégica está dando
recetas para ciertos sectores
específicos habló directamente a los
pescadores habló al sector turismo
hablan los agricultores y dando ciertos
incentivos beneficios pero no sabemos
eso cómo se articula con la política
general y eso es lamentable porque
estamos en una segunda vuelta en donde
el perú está en una de sus crisis
más agudas desde los años 80 no hemos
estado en una situación como ésta enzo
el guerra nacional de lima su opinión
usted que es analista en la opinión
pública en marketing político su opinión
de la dinámica que ha tenido este debate
ya mauricio daba su opinión sobre la
exposición de las ideas que ha tenido
que han tenido estos dos candidatos cuál
es su opinión
bien en principio han apuntado un poco a
estrategias perfectamente diseñadas
mientras keiko fujimori tenía el
escenario principal para poder atacar al
candidato castillo y tratar de bajarle
la llanta con la finalidad que su esos
dos puntos que le están diferenciando
según las últimas encuestas difundidas
el día de hoy en perú me dan pues frenar
dicha dicha subida o dicho liderazgo que
tiene castillo en las encuestas mientras
por el lado del castillo la estrategia
también previsible que tenía sobre todo
para luchar en esta en este debate
estaba apuntando principalmente a
aclarar aquellos fantasmas que le habían
atribuido durante el desarrollo de su
campaña por otro lado y lo que sí me
sorprende es evidentemente cierta
pobreza
en ambos candidatos por ejemplo para
hablar en cuanto a la estadística y en
cuanto al reflejo de los ataques por
ejemplo keiko fujimori anunció y
atribuyó en más de una oportunidad que
la izquierda y los gobiernos regionales
de ese espectro político tenían en la
mayor deficiencia cuando en realidad si
hacemos una contabilidad entre la
ejecución presupuestal del año 2019 y
2020 justo los gobiernos regionales y
gobiernos locales de keiko fujimori han
tenido menos nivel de ejecución
presupuestal que los de perú libre y el
candidato y perú libre tampoco se
defendió y habló acerca del tema
entonces si hay una pobreza en materia
estadística por otro lado en esta
dinámica
keiko fujimori se muestra un poco más
lucha por la experiencia que tiene en el
debate y que el candidato castillo
intenta dar la performance en relación a
ciertos manejos de aspectos
y coincido con zabaleta en el sentido de
que la explicación del cómo lo van a
hacer de cómo están recibiendo o cómo
van a recibir la salud económica del
país permitiría acaso todas estas
demandas de promesas que están
realizando ambos candidatos nadie hace
esas explicaciones y creo que los
votantes están esperando mucho más de
ambos candidatos pues qué les parece de
mauricio y eso si conectamos de nuevo
con arequipa allí en el sur de perú para
la continuación de este cuarto tema de
debate presidencial aquí en france24
digamos
todos nuestros niños y jóvenes puedan
tener este acceso y tener la
comunicación y recibir los contenidos
que ellos esperan por parte del estado
será una prioridad también modernizar
las escuelas que ahora están abandonadas
priorizando aquellas que no servís
necesitan sus servicios básicos pero
sabiendo que vamos a regresar una
educación presencial tenemos que ampliar
la infraestructura educativa y para eso
hemos anunciado la construcción de 3.000
colegios más a nivel nacional colegios
modernos colegios donde simplemente en
clases de arte de cultura de educación
física de educación cívica vamos a
mejorar la educación en nuestro país
gracias candidata keiko fujimori de
fuerza popular ahora es el turno del
candidato pedro castillo de perú libre
el también cuenta con tres minutos para
su exposición adelante cándida gracias
antes me decía antes un segundo me
decían que soy machista y yo tengo mi
madre quien la quiero mucho
hija mía mis hermanas me gustaría que mi
contrincante por primera vez en la
historia pida perdón a las mujeres que
fueron esterilizadas y yo no voy a
levantar una palanca para electrocutar a
mi madre
en cuanto la educación yo soy maestro de
primaria 24 años de servicio allá no hay
presencia del estado mi escuela está
declarada en emergencia hace tiempo por
el inglés y está rajada de punta a punta
lo que hubiese viene a ofrecer me
hubiese gustado
la señora fujimori en el 2017 cuando
visitamos a su bancada no solamente
pidiendo el nombramiento de miles de
maestros con más de 20 25 años del
contrato que se les nombre no solamente
el pago de la deuda sino que se declaré
a la educación como derecho
constitucional porque tenía la bancada
mayoritaria en el parlamento porque las
leyes ya se han allá donde están las
estas curules entonces creemos
importante que la educación no puede ser
un servicio acá no hay es educarte si
puedes
o la chica que leer con la cola no puede
ser un privilegio y una discriminación
con la educación los niños no pueden
seguir frustrándose los niños tienen
talentos hay que descubrir los talentos
en las computadoras hoy en un mundo
virtualizado lo que tenemos que gestar
que hay que implementar la currícula no
de arriba de no de arriba hacia abajo
poniendo en ministros improvisados basta
después de puertas giratorias tenemos
que implementar la educación desde el
seno de la de seno de la comunidad desde
el seno de lo maestro del seno de los
niños que hay que valorar a la escuela
dos entidades de la sociedad que tiene
que ir en la familia con la escuela son
entes indesligable es en la sociedad que
vuelvan los valores a la casa que no le
mientan al país que no vuelvan a poner
paneles mentirosos en las grandes
ciudades que no le digan que le van a
quitar sus cosas porque eso era quitar
su mochila en los niños
cuando yo pregunto a los niños te
pregunté a los niños cualquier ciudadano
cualquier compatriota pregunté ese niño
que se va al colegio dígale en la
mochila que llevas puesta del gobierno
el zapato que llevo ha puesto del
gobierno la alimentación que lleva
dentro del gobierno y no donde esté el
estado donde esté el gobierno nuestra
prioridad será la educación los jóvenes
al terminar la secundaria tienen que
tener la gran oportunidad de tener el
ingreso libre en las universidades como
derecho constitucional descubriremos
capacidades descubriremos talentos pero
primero la educación segundo educación
tercero la educación los grandes
desarrollo de los países se hacen con
esta herramienta la educación primero
porque antes que todo el perú gracias
candidato pedro castillo culminada esta
primera parte ahora pasamos al momento
del diálogo recordemos que cada
candidato cuenta con cuatro minutos para
intervenir y administrarlos como mejor
lo considere creo que los candidatos ya
conocen bien la dinámica de este bloque
y la intención es que entre ambos puedan
dialogar y debatir sus propuestas les
parece si comenzamos a hablar
acerca del enfoque de género respetar y
a su gobierno el enfoque de género en la
educación básica introduciría cambios si
es así cuáles serían algunos de ustedes
desea comer comenzar
adelante candidata keiko fujimori
como mujer y como madre voy a siempre
rechazar cualquier posibilidad de
esterilización forzada
esto se está investigando y será el
poder judicial quien finalmente
determine si hubiese alguna
responsabilidad individual
pero señor castillo no mienta porque
esto no fue una política de estado
deje de lanzar piedras y hablar piedras
sobre el tema del enfoque de género
nosotros creemos que es fundamental que
los contenidos
en el sector educación sean también
evaluados por los padres de familia y
nosotros lo que creemos es en la
igualdad del género en que los niños y
niñas desde temprana edad sepan
reconocer y saber que tienen los mismos
derechos y deberes esa es la visión de
fuerza popular gracias candidata su
turno o candidato
la situación gente en la situación de
género viene de casa viene de familia y
eso sé y eso se tiene que
y profundizar en la institución
educativa
nosotros los maestros conocemos a los
niños conocemos a los infantes conocemos
a los jóvenes estudiantes para nosotros
los maestros cada niño es una realidad
distinta cada niño es un mundo y por eso
es necesario inducir que lo profesión lo
con los maestros no solamente tenemos
que capacitar les remunerarles yo puedo
tener el mejor maestro pagado en frente
de los niños pero qué hago si al niño
aparte que tiene problemas internos
familiares
el niño se duerme en el aula el problema
educativo es un problema estructural es
un problema es una tarea compartida de
toda la sociedad recuperemos la escuela
por favor queridos compatriotas
recuperemos el valor nuestros hijos no
pueden estar mendigando derechos
constitucionales en la calle no se puede
mendigar no se puede juzgar o no se
puede ver de que los hijos se eduquen
como ir a comprar una pastilla hoy en
este marco privatista de la educación
donde todo está al revés
se ve que la educación es como una isla
que para llegar a ella tienes que
navegar un océano de sacrificio entonces
pasa por revalorar no solamente al
maestro sino revalorar su sangre su
origen sus lenguas sus tradiciones
los idiomas su cultura el perú tiene
mucho 32 este tiene más de 30 más de 30
climas eso tenemos que valorarla porque
también eso influye en la formación de
las personas
bien permítanos y hacerles una pregunta
respecto al tema educación ciencia e
innovación para ambos candidatos
respecto a la carrera pública
magisterial mantendrían el enfoque de
meritocracia para la contratación y el
incremento de sueldos de los maestros
cuál es la propuesta de cada uno de
ustedes para que puedan establecer las
diferencias los electores quien se anima
a responder adelante candidato castillo
en el perú se han implementado más de 17
reformas educativas pero reformas
educativas de guerrilla y siempre se le
culpaba al maestro
la evaluación docente es una tarea
inherente a la labor docente exigimos
que el maestro se le evalúe
permanentemente hay que formar al
maestro por eso es necesario en cada
región una universidad pedagógica
permanente basta de burocracias como es
posible que tengas a unidos del
desligado de la realidad delegada es un
maestro que no tiene internet y si
nosotros impulsamos la educación como
derecho a una educación gratuita de
calidad y pública el internet tiene que
ser gratuito también entonces en este
mundo virtualizado tenemos que tener
mucho cuidado con la implementación no
solamente de las reformas educativas
porque cualquier reforma induce en la
casa e induce e induce en el estudiante
la reforma no tienen que ser de arriba
de abajo de arriba hacia abajo tiene que
ser de abajo hacia arriba con la
participación ciudadana y no solamente
verde culpar al maestro cuando se rompió
la luna de la escuela sino que tiene que
ver una formación
candidata keiko fujimori si parece que
el señor pedro castillo siempre va de
esta pregunta los periodistas se lo han
hecho varias veces pero él no la
contesta con claridad
nosotros y fortaleceremos la carrera
pública magisterial es importante dar
capacitaciones constantes a nuestros
maestros la meritocracia tiene que ser
un valor que se tenga que siempre tener
en cuenta y mejorar las remuneraciones
aprovecho esta oportunidad también para
ratificar nuestro compromiso de
fortalecer a las unido hay muchas
especulaciones en este caso el
contrincante planea cerrarla y yo creo
que más allá de los defectos y virtudes
que ha tenido está logrando mejorar la
calidad de la enseñanza sin embargo hay
otro aspecto también que tenemos que
tomar en cuenta hay regiones en donde se
han cerrado las universidades públicas y
los estudiantes se han visto muy
afectados para ellos buscaremos el
traslado que se les considere en otras
universidades para que ellos puedan
seguir con su carrera universidad y
universitaria de manera virtual gracias
candidata a recordar a la población que
nos sigue en este debate presidencial
2021 desde la ciudad blanca de arequipa
que al candidato pedro castillo le queda
un minuto con dos segundos y a la
candidata keiko fujimori le queda un
minuto con cuarenta y dos segundos que
les parece candidatos si hablamos
respecto a la ciencia e innovación que
mecanismos de acción inmediata
ejecutarán para generar la alta
investigación e innovación en ciencia y
tecnología alguno de ustedes desea
iniciar
adelante candidato castillo si yo
quisiera agradecer el doctor montoya
todavía con una persona comprometida con
la ciencia y la tecnología innovación
vamos a crear el ministerio de la
ciencia y tecnología investigación
porque el perú no puede ser solamente un
país primario exportador hoy ni los
botones de la camisa son nuestros
queremos importante que a partir de este
ministerio y descentralizando porque no
una universidad descentralizar por
ejemplo la universidad de san marcos en
la macrosur en la macro centro en la
macro norte igual que la universidad de
ingeniería
tenemos que impulsar el desarrollo
integral del país no puede estar
centralizado en ese entender la
investigación tiene que ser nuestra
prioridad y darle un verdadero
presupuesto al sector de investigación
el 2017 el ministro y el gobierno
destinó el 0.04 por ciento a las
universidades para el sector de
investigación y que se investiga que se
investigue el el perú tiene que ser un
gestor de su propio desarrollo y
amparado juntamente con la juventud para
industrializar el país
gracias candidato pedro castillo de perú
libre a continuación el turno de la
candidata keiko fujimori de fuerza
popular adelante candidata
señalamos claramente en nuestro plan de
gobierno que tenemos que invertir en
ciencia y tecnología además promoveremos
políticas públicas que permitan que
ciudadanos peruanos que están en otros
países
y que trabajan en este rubro puedan
regresar a nuestro país y que
contribuyan con nosotros pero también es
importante señalar que nosotros nosotros
rechazamos la politización de la ciencia
como por ejemplo ocurrió hace algunos
días atrás cuando el señor castillo
visitó al científico manolo fernández y
anunció mentirosamente que se incluiría
a él en su equipo técnico luego él lo
rechazó este tipo de iniciativas debemos
de rechazar y no utilizar a estos
expertos que están colaborando con
nuestro país
quiero aprovechar estos segundos que nos
quedan para dar un mensaje a los jóvenes
ampliaremos el programa beca 18 acá lo
importante
y fortalecer los programas no importa
quién los haya creado la historia de
nuestro país no se inicia cada 5 años y
esto es un programa que ha ayudado mucho
a la juventud
destinaremos 300 millones adicionales
para que nuestros jóvenes tengan
posibilidad de estudiar pero
enfocándonos también en las zonas
vulnerables tuve la oportunidad de
conversar con los comités autodefensa de
las zonas del vrae y ellos nos decían
beca 18 para nuestros hijos para ellos
todo nuestro compromiso gracias
candidata keiko fujimori gracias
candidato pedro castillo ahora daremos
base a las preguntas ciudadanas sobre
este tema educación ciencia e innovación
[Música]
buenas noches mi nombre es katherine
carranza o moscol y soy de la ciudad de
ica me gustaría hacerles la siguiente
pregunta vivimos en un país donde
existen muchas personas que tienen la
capacidad de crear y desarrollar
tecnología pero el estado no los apoya
qué estrategias propone su gobierno para
apoyar en el desarrollo de tecnologías e
innovación en el perú
y
de acuerdo al sorteo damos pase para
responder por el espacio de un minuto y
medio a la candidata keiko fujimori de
fuerza popular adelante candidata
catherine buenas noches efectivamente
nuestro país invierte muy poco en
ciencia tecnología y esto se ve
reflejado en las pocas patentes
mundiales que tiene el perú en
comparación con el resto del mundo
incluso si nos comparamos con otros
países de la región tenemos que invertir
considero yo podemos dar incentivos
tributarios de tal manera que de esta
manera premiamos a aquellas empresas que
invierten y logran tener éxito utilizaré
estos 50 minutos restantes para seguir
hablando del tema de educación
apostamos para regresar a la educación
presencial y para ello es importante que
el programa halle warm a los desayunos
escolares continúen y se amplíen pero no
quedarnos solamente en eso sino
ampliarlo también a los almuerzos
escolares y sabiendo que la producción
nacional por ejemplo se ha visto
afectada conversando con los hermanos en
el trujillo hemos dicho que las compras
estatales por ejemplo para los calzados
escolares el 40% de las compras
estatales estará dedicado
específicamente para la micro y pequeña
empresa nacional
de esta manera creceremos todos juntos
gracias candidata keiko fujimori
igualmente el candidato pedro castillo
de perú libre tiene un minuto 30
segundos para responder a la pregunta
ciudadana adelante y nuestra prioridad
nuestra prioridad es invertir en la
ciencia la investigación
cómo es posible que tantos ciudadanos
con una sede seguirá avanzando se vean
frustrados no ha habido gobiernos que
impulsen en el congreso han habido
muchas comisiones de educación y les ha
importado un pepino la educación del
pueblo pero en eso desarrollo creemos
importante que el desarrollo empieza por
la educación darle un presupuesto real a
los jóvenes talentosos para hacer una
convocatoria nacional para que no
solamente impulsen el desarrollo
tecnológico sino que también en el marco
de los universitarios un presupuesto
real que salgan del país vayan a traer
nueva tecnología y regresen al país para
impulsar el desarrollo tecnológico
científico en el país en todos los
rincones y en coordinación con las
municipalidades distritales provinciales
los gobiernos regionales todos los
espacios y ahí mi reconocimiento
a las mujeres a las damas a las
señoritas
las jóvenes que son impulsores de su
propio desarrollo que se encuentran
frustradas en ese marco la educación
tiene que ser una educación abierta no
solamente dentro de las aulas fuera de
las aulas comprometiendo a las
autoridades a los ministerios pero con
un real presupuesto
gracias a ambos candidatos por responder
la consulta de la ciudadanía ahora
escuchamos otra pregunta que tiene la
población
y
buenas noches mi nombre es franja dor
flores negra
vivo iquitos mi pregunta de la siguiente
la pandemia ha evidenciado la enorme
diferencia entre la educación rural y la
urbana
en las zonas rurales hay poco acceso a
internet las escuelas no tienen
computadoras los padres desconocen el
uso de las tic's los maestros hacen el
trabajo sin tener ante muchas veces
arriesgando su vida que dar a su
gobierno para poder acabar con estas
brechas y de qué manera se mejorará la
condición laboral del docente
y
nuevamente el turno de intervención se
ha invertido iniciamos entonces con la
respuesta del candidato pedro castillo
de perú libre adelante candidato tiene
usted un minuto con 30 segundos mi
saludo para la región de loreto
a los hombres de caballo cocha a los
alumnos que están allí en la frontera
con brasil donde por culpa del abandono
del estado los niños que están en la
frontera
hablan portugués en vez de hablar
castellano los maestros para llegar a
acciones educativas tienen que viajar
siete días en agua lo hemos hecho le
hemos vivido eso tiene que ser el
servicio de internet tiene que ser una
prioridad el año pasado
la estrategia frustrada y fracasada de
aprendo en casa eso se vio no solamente
en loreto sino a nivel nacional
solamente el 26 por ciento de la
población escolar tuvieron acceso a este
servicio y el resto
loreto es una de las regiones más
golpeadas no solamente por la pandemia
sino por este sistema educativo no
solamente impulsar para que el profesor
esté a la altura tecnológica sino llamar
urgentemente a los gobernadores
regionales y que el gobierno asuma que
el internet tiene que ser una prioridad
no puede estar en el siglo 21 en un
mundo globalizado el momento
virtualizado desligado los niños de sus
maestros no es solamente darle un tablet
o la computadora sino que tiene que ver
un sistema real de educación desde el
ente rector que es el ministerio ocación
de acuerdo a la realidad regional y
local donde se desarrolla se vuelven de
desenvolver es gracias señor pedro
castillo
ahora pedimos la respuesta a la pregunta
ciudadana a la candidata keiko fujimori
estimado franco
hace pocos días estuve en yurimaguas
estado en iquitos y efectivamente la
conexión de internet es pésima
y me imagino que en las zonas más
alejadas prácticamente no existe por eso
que la educación virtual ha sido un
reverendo fracaso
nosotros estamos preocupados en lograr
la conectividad de que iquitos deje de
ser una isla no solamente la
conectividad terrestre la conectividad
ferroviaria ecológica pero para lograr
la conectividad del internet será
importante lograr culminar con la red
dorsal podrá podremos adquirir el
servicio de internet satelital yo creo
que de esta manera vamos a poder ayudar
en la conectividad y a los maestros que
trabajan en las zonas más alejadas por
ese esfuerzo y ese sacrificio deben
recibir una remuneración más alta
y les reconozca este sacrificio que
ellos hacen pero finalmente a una
reflexión el señor castillo se jacta de
ser maestro de ser profesor pero dejó
abandonados a sus alumnos ha vivido en
los últimos meses o años de la licencia
sindical y no se preocupó de enseñarle a
sus gracias candidata keiko fujimori
también al candidato pedro castillo por
responder las preguntas de la población
ahora daremos base a las palabras de
cierre del bloque educación ciencia
ciencia e innovación para lo cual cada
uno contará con un minuto iniciamos con
la candidata keiko fujimori de fuerza
popular adelante candidata
sé que muchos niños probablemente nos
estén mirando acompañando a sus papitos
viendo este debate
a ustedes a quienes he visto en varios
de mis encuentros les agradezco por su
entusiasmo por su alegría por esos
abrazos y esas sonrisas que ustedes me
regalan me comprometo con ustedes
queridos niños a que puedan regresar
pronto a sus escuelas a que puedan
regresar nuevamente abrazar a sus amigos
les pido como mamá que se porten bien
que ayuden en su casa
que no dejen que les digan que no se
pueden hacer las cosas cuando uno se lo
propone cuando uno tiene las metas
claras si es que uno quiere si puede y
yo sé que todos ustedes y todos juntos
podremos gracias candidata fujimori es
el turno del candidato pedro castillo de
perú libre adelante sí gracias saludar a
toda la población escolar a más de los 8
millones de estudiantes y en los que no
las galas que las ha desertado este
sistema a los que están en la calle que
no ha habido la oportunidad de darles
una oportunidad para que estudie y en
especial a mis niños y a mis padres de
familia empuña a estos niños especiales
que las tengo también presente saben que
siempre estaré con ustedes y espero que
no solamente lucharé para que ustedes
dejen de alumbrarse con un mechero hoy
de cara al bicentenario no solamente
sigan sacando agua de servicio sino
llegaremos con internet mejoraremos las
escuela
le daremos prioridad pensando en ustedes
pensando en su grave problemas de
desnutrición estaremos siempre presente
para contribuir con la educación no más
pobres en un país rico
de maestro
gracias hacemos una pausa comercial y
regresamos con el quinto bloque para
tratar otro tema muy importante como es
la lucha contra la corrupción e
integridad pública
finalizó cerró el tema número 4 de este
debate presidencial en perú educación
ciencia e innovación en donde quedó en
evidencia la brecha en cuanto a la
tecnología que ha dejado en evidencia la
pandemia de kobe 19 sobre todo en las
zonas rurales allí los candidatos le
respondían a uno de los ciudadanos en la
ciudad de iquitos en el departamento de
loreto en el norte del país en el
amazonas peruano sobre los problemas
para acceder a la conexión de internet
que es una realidad no sólo de perú sino
una realidad común para muchos países de
américa latina- hablaron de un internet
masificado prioritario para esas zonas
rurales y fujimori también habló de la
posibilidad de empezar a establecer el
internet satelital vamos a ver algunas
de las otras prioridades que tienen los
peruanos y bien este debate está siendo
televisado hoy para que los ciudadanos
conozcan las propuestas de los
ciudadanos los peruanos tienen muchas
dudas tienen muchas preocupaciones en
torno al futuro que pueda tener el país
y hay otros temas aparte de educación
economía y pandemia que también
veamos
pedro castillo y keiko fujimori agua y
aceite él es líder de izquierda y ella
de derecha por lo que las posturas de
los ciudadanos están muy divididas no
vamos a perder de estas libertades no
vamos a tener a un dictador
tenemos que pelear por la democracia no
queremos ser un venezuela no queremos
ser un cubano queremos ser un knick
aragua queremos mantener nuestras
libertades eso es todo los simpatizantes
de keiko han vinculado castillo con el
grupo terrorista sendero luminoso en más
de una ocasión además dicen que sus
planes de gobierno amenazan a las
empresas transnacionales y organismos
constitucionales de hecho parte de sus
ofrecimientos son estatizar el país y
redactar una nueva constitución por otro
lado el antifujimorismo ha cogido mucha
fuerza en estas elecciones es una
organización criminal con gobernado con
su padre dijo algo cuando su padre se
iba a esterilizar a las mujeres del
campo en contra de su voluntad no fue
cómplice y no solamente eso quiere tomar
el poder porque sabe lo que le viene
detrás del crepe de la carne
delito gravísimo que cometió los
peruanos están cansados de ser
gobernados por corruptos y keiko ha
estado involucrada en el caso la valla
pto
por eso se adentran en el tema de las
elecciones ante el futuro que se les
avecina ha aumentado el interés de los
peruanos en la campaña electoral
respecto a lo que vimos en la primera
vuelta que era un elector desconectado
totalmente de la elección ahora si vemos
mayor preocupación mayor seguimiento en
la campaña ante los extremos que
presentan los candidatos al balotaje por
la presidencia de perú firmaron un
acuerdo para respetar el orden
constitucional del país sin embargo hay
dudas de que cumplan su promesa
vamos al análisis con nuestros invitados
comienzo en esta oportunidad la ronda a
la inversa comienzo preguntándole a enzo
en la ciudad de lima sus opiniones sobre
este tema de la educación ciencia e
innovación y también como vi a los
candidatos desenvolverse en este tema en
particular
bueno creo igual que se termina quedando
cortado no solamente el diagnóstico sino
también la solución y también la
explicación de cómo lo van a llevar si
bien es cierto que jcco ha planteado que
con mejor precisión el cómo extender o
la alternativa de extender el internet
faltó de pronto el involucrar también a
la empresa privada que actualmente da
servicios de internet a nivel nacional
para involucrarlos en algunos proyectos
rurales que con principio fueron como
proyecto país y encumbrados con la
finalidad de poder arreglar estas
diferencias en lo rural sin embargo no
ha tenido mucho éxito finalmente porque
el compromiso con estas empresas
privadas no se llegó a avanzar más allá
de sólo algunos algunas muestras sin
embargo y muy muy aparte de ello
el desarrollo de la tecnología el
involucrar a las instituciones a la
empresa privada o incluso a crear un
fondo para la investigación pero con
responsabilidad del estado no se habló
también por ejemplo del aumento
presupuestal que podría haber para
financiar aquellos segmentos de
educación faltó nuevamente el explicar
más allá de entiendo que no se están
generando mayores compromisos por lo
menos no en este en este segmento
usualmente este segmento termina
haciendo el fuerte del señor castillo
porque yo es maestro es profesor de
escuela aprovecho keiko fujimori para
poder atacarlo por el tema de la
licencia sindical porque evidentemente
no enseñan no perdió oportunidad al
aprovechado de hecho en cada una de las
intervenciones de tratar de atacar y
probablemente provocará el candidato
castillo consideró que el plan del
castillo
y un poco más sereno en ese en ese
ataque y respuesta a pesar de que empezó
el bloque sí con un ataque contundente
en relación al tema que se le atribuye a
alberto fujimori con las
esterilizaciones forzosas
esta dinámica evidentemente puso un poco
tenso en el inicio del debate pero luego
él ha intentado no tratar de caer ya en
mayor provocación y concentrarse un poco
más en el nivel de propuestas
mauricio le voy a dar la palabra al
final de este bloque porque ya
comenzaron a debatir en torno al tema
número 5 que es lucha contra la
corrupción e integridad pública y pues
no queremos perder detalle de lo que
están diciendo vamos entonces a
conectarnos con arequipa y cuando
regresemos comienzo por ustedes mauricio
muchos años en nuestra historia sin duda
también atacó al gobierno de mi padre
atacó a los gobiernos anteriores a él y
atacó a los gobiernos sucesivos
hay varios expresidentes procesados por
eso y justamente por eso no me puedo
permitir fallarles en esta lucha vamos a
hacer y tomar una serie de iniciativas
para enfrentar y prevenir este flagelo
en primer lugar
fortaleceremos la contraloría el ente
encargado de luchar y de prevenir se le
aumentará su presupuesto pero también se
le tiene que dar capacidad sancionadora
y control concurrente he anunciado
también la creación de un alto
comisionado conformado por personas
lejos de la política miembros de la
sociedad civil
que se encargarán de evaluar de dar
propuestas de fiscalizar desde el
presidente de la república hasta el
último funcionario
hemos señalado también que
implementaremos el programa
transparencia 100% esto permitirá
que los medios de prensa que los
ciudadanos participen proactivamente en
todos los procesos de adquisición de
compras de parte del estado y aquí
quiero mencionar también un ejemplo que
ha funcionado muy bien en la ejecución
de los juegos panamericanos conversando
con el señor carlos neuhaus él me
comentaba que los contratos de gobierno
a gobierno ayudaron mucho para reducir y
no tener actos de corrupción y además
aplicaron en todo el proceso el control
concurrente esto significa que en cada
decisión que se tomaba la contraloría
los acompañaba en todo momento estas
obras concluyeron con éxito el señor
carlos neuhaus cumplió con todas las
exigencias que se le pedía a nuestro
país es más devolvió cerca de 300
millones pudo ahorrar y tener una
gestión impecable eso es lo que hará
nuestro viaje gracias candidata keiko
fujimori de fuerza popular ahora es el
turno del candidato pedro castillo de
perú libre también cuenta con tres
minutos para su exposición adelante
candidato pueblo peruano
yo quisiera agradecer a todas las
ciudades del país que claman en las
calles y en las plazas una lucha frontal
contra la corrupción
no les suena a ustedes
qué hablar de corrupción es sinónimo de
los fujimori simó
no les suena a ustedes
que para hablar de corrupción tienes que
tener una pizca de moral
la corrupción está enquistada en todos
los estamentos del estado hay corrupción
por todo lado y en ese contexto hay que
entender que la corrupción ha ido más
allá ha corrompido la moral de la
juventud de la familia de la sociedad
los funcionarios en este marco y estos
últimos años
es normal desear ante una obra aunque
robes en en ese contexto queremos
importante de que luchar por la
corrupción significa fortalecer a la
contraloría ampliando sus facultades
para que sancionen directamente a los
corruptos
y es necesario crear el consejo nacional
anticorrupción integrado por el
presidente del poder judicial el fiscal
de la nación el defensor del pueblo un
representante de la iglesia y otros que
aman a la democracia del país al cual
personalmente la presidir e
vamos a fortalecer las fiscalías
especializadas anticorrupción
ampliando sus facultades a sí mismo
desde nuestra bancada
solicitaremos que se mejoren las leyes
penales para sancionar eficazmente
fiscalmente al corruptor y al corrompido
y los corruptos deben ser inhabilitados
perpetuamente para que no vuelvan a
contratar con el estado a césar lo que
es del césar y al pueblo lo que es del
pueblo
como presidente promover que la sociedad
civil se organice para fiscalizar a
todos los funcionarios y al propio
presidente de la república
devolveremos por dignidad
a las fuerzas del orden no solamente la
moral sino el honor
y subir y su dignidad
candidato castillo todavía tiene 23
segundos desea utilizarlos
sí gracias creemos importante que la
corrupción debe tener ya hoy en día un
tope a partir del 28 de julio no
solamente haremos un barrido
de la corrupción
en los rincones del país
sino que es necesario hacerlo caiga qin
gang
gracias candidato castillo culminada a
esta parte y para explicar aún mejor y
más las propuestas de cada uno de los
candidatos pasamos ahora al momento del
diálogo ambos cuentan con cuatro minutos
para intervenir que los deberán
administrar de la manera más conveniente
la finalidad de este bloque es que ambos
candidatos a la presidencia de la
república- dialoguen sobre sus
principales propuestas para que los
electores puedan apreciar las
diferencias entre estas propuestas
les sugerimos el tema acerca de los
mecanismos de promoción de la integridad
en la función pública cuáles serían
estos mecanismos de la promoción de la
integridad en la función pública que
ustedes en un eventual gobierno
implementarían quien se anima a iniciar
la respuesta candidata fujimori
si el señor cerró a disculpe el señor
castillo habla de propuestas para
inhabilitar a los funcionarios
muchas de estas normas han sido
aprobadas por la banca de fuerza popular
del congreso anterior donde se aprobó la
muerte civil
y los impedimentos para que los
corruptos y terroristas no participen en
el estado
y esa es la razón por la que su papá
político no se encuentra el día de hoy
él quiso ser miembro de su plancha
presidencial pero está impedido porque
tiene una sentencia por corrupción
basta ir a la región de junín para saber
todas las obras inconclusas que se
quedaron por la pésima gestión del señor
se ron así es que si usted quiere hablar
de propuestas primero mire lo que fuerza
popular ya hizo
candidato castillo sugiero que usted
trate de superar su obsesión con cerrón
acá el candidato es pedro castillo
no la va a ver en mi gestión de igual
manera ninguna persona vinculada con
extremistas
creemos importante manifestarles de que
la gestión pública tiene que hacerse
transparentemente yo he visto a los
gobernadores regionales a los alcaldes
formando cola en el medio
cargando quiz de su región
cargando regalos de su región y sin
vergüenza mente el funcionario les pide
a los alcaldes a los bonos letra m tanto
para darte tanto les dan un millón y ese
millón de soles no llega al pueblo se
quede en el camino el 10 por ciento el
15 por ciento por eso cuando queremos
combatir la corrupción y recuperar los
recursos estratégicos del país por eso
es que tiembla la corrupción te pone en
paneles te dicen que eres terruco que
eres chavista que eres comunista se han
inventado tantas cosas el pueblo conoce
el pueblo sabe saben por qué porque se
acabó la planilla dorada se acabó los
sueldos dorados se acabaron las más
bajas y aquí anunció que tenemos que
tener moral para decirla hoy en este
momento vuelvo a decir que renunciar al
sueldo presidencialista conducir el
destino del país con un sueldo de
maestro y agradezco a los compatriotas
que están asumiendo en el entorno mío
que van a ser parte no solamente del
equipo técnico sino de nuestro gobierno
que han asumido la responsabilidad de
bajar
el sueldo la mitad
porque primero es el país no es primero
el bolsillo no es primero tu interés
personal yo estoy aquí por el perú no me
mueve otro interés
si me movieron interés personal o de
grupo hace tiempo y no es no estuviera
acá o de repente estuviera en la cárcel
bien candidata fujimori
el señor castillo como creerle que el
señor se ron no participa en su grupo
político si él ha impuesto el vocero yo
me pregunto dónde está el señor kurt
burneo al que usted anuncio con bombos y
platillos como miembros su equipo
técnico el señor se ron se lo impidió
pues ya sabemos quién manda favor las
cosas claras
y además
yo me comprometí en todo momento al
inicio la campaña anoté a roquear
y lo he cumplido a cabalidad aquí los
únicos que se repite lo que dan son
ustedes mismos cuando salen informes
periodísticos claramente donde hay más
de 400 más de 240 miembros del movev en
miembros de perú libre participando
activamente en su partido
voy a regresar a las propuestas porque
yo no estoy aquí para lanzar piedras
como lo hace el señor castillo la
corrupción tiene que ver también con la
indolencia con la incapacidad con la
indiferencia del estado para hacer las
cosas por ejemplo una de las necesidades
básicas fundamentales en el medio de
esta pandemia es el acceso al agua
más del 30 por ciento de familias en
nuestro país no tienen agua potable
el ministerio de salud dice lávese las
manos mantengan el distanciamiento
social con que agua me pregunto
en estos asentamientos que llevan años
esperando que tienen que lidiar con
mafias para poder adquirir con tanto
esfuerzo
esas aguas que utilizan para salvar la
vida de su familia a ellos me dirijo nos
hemos comprometido a construir ya dar
tres millones de conexiones de agua y
alcantarillado pero mientras esto ocurra
yo no voy a mirar de costado no hemos
lanzado el programa agua para ti
tendremos 2500 camiones cisternas
repartiendo el agua gratuitamente a
todas las familias que no tienen agua
el estado no puede ser indiferente
frente a tanta necesidad el agua es vida
el agua nos ayuda a combatir la pandemia
el agua nos ayuda a enfrentar la anemia
en nuestros hijos agua para ti es mi
compromiso con todas las mamás gracias
candidata keiko candidato a pedro
castillo puede usted en proseguir pueblo
peruano
s exijo que ese oxígeno y oxígeno que
necesita este para darle a tu familia
que quito la corrupción
es internet que no tienes para darle a
tus hijos te la llevó la corrupción es
agua que no tienes en la punta del cerro
te llevo la corrupción
esas necesidades grandes que tiene el
país se lo ha llevado la corrupción
yo no sé
y aún se mantiene sin trabajar
y aún viven así composta mente y
diciendo que van a solucionar los
grandes problemas en el país
creemos importante de que para combatir
la corrupción tenemos que empezar por
casa
y hay que empezar por la escuela por la
juventud hay que empezar por las
universidades
yo quisiera saludar a la juventud
que hacen un esfuerzo saliendo a
manifestarse que hay que limpiar la
corrupción porque ellos se criaron
distintos
porque saben que ellos educaron con el
esfuerzo de sus padres porque saben que
hay que llevar un pan a la boca es con
el esfuerzo de su trabajo por eso es
necesario que a la corrupción hay que
barrer cómo se barren las escaleras de
arriba hacia abajo
y para eso estamos acá lo decimos porque
somos personas que hemos combatido otros
flagelos como el suelo como el problema
como el problema del terrorismo como el
problema de la cun de la delincuencia
hoy vamos a combatir estos graves
problemas que aquejan al país de cara al
bicentenario
bien le recordamos a la candidata keiko
fujimori que tiene 17 segundos el
candidato pero castillo tiene 18
segundos quien quisiera comenzar para
redondear el tema en su participación
final candidata keiko fujimori
si así como he hablado del tema del agua
otro de los grandes problemas que existe
en nuestro país es el acceso a los lotes
o el acceso a la vivienda
y aquí muchas familias tienen que lidiar
también con traficantes de tierra
gracias candidato castillo
y en todo caso de que se devuelva la
plata de la corrupción hay que darle
muerte civil a los corruptos y que
devuelvan todo lo rogado para darle un
pan a nuestros hijos para darle libertad
en el marco educativo de la salud a toda
la población a nivel nacional
muchas gracias a ambos candidatos ahora
daremos pase a las preguntas ciudadanas
y
buenas noches mi nombre es fabiola
requena vidal y vivo en la ciudad de
lima
mi pregunta es la siguiente para luchar
contra la corrupción en el sector
estatal es necesario tener comentarios y
servidores públicos que hayan demostrado
ser personas idóneas para el ejercicio
de su cargo en un eventual gobierno suyo
y en base a su plan de gobierno cuál
sería la medida más efectiva para
fortalecer la ética en la función
pública
[Música]
bien en esta parte en la que hay la
participación ciudadana de acuerdo con
el sorteo damos pase para responder por
el espacio de un minuto y medio a la
candidata keiko fujimori de fuerza
popular adelante candidata
buenas noches fabiola
efectivamente muchos de los problemas de
la corrupción está enquistada desde hace
décadas en todo el sector público dentro
de las propuestas que nosotros
planteamos también es la protección al
denunciante muchas veces los
funcionarios de menor rango tienen temor
de hacer la denuncia contra su jefe y es
por eso que a través de esta propuesta
nosotros vamos a proteger a las personas
que nos ayuden a combatir este flagelo
pero como me quedé con los pocos
segundos de la última intervención
quería hablarles del programa del
problema del tráfico de tierras y para
eso hemos anunciado el programa familia
en la que vamos a entregar más de 200
mil lotes
y vivienda de futura vivienda
concatenada con el programa techo propio
de esta manera vamos a ayudar a miles de
familias que están esperando su casa
propia y que el estado no hace nada por
ellos
impulsaremos además el programa cofopri
entregaremos 2 millones de títulos de
propiedad el saneamiento físico legal no
puede ser la excusa para que el estado
no te dé los servicios adicionales que
tú estás esperando
gracias candidata keiko fujimori de
fuerza popular ahora es el turno del
candidato pedro castillo de perú libre
para responder la pregunta ciudadana
tiene también un minuto con 30 segundos
adelante candidato
y ya decía que para hablar de corrupción
tienes que tener moral y no evada es el
gran problema que tiene el perú de cara
al bicentenario para conducir los
destinos del país tienes que tener la
moral para llegar a cada pueblo a cada
barrio a cada rincón
creo que en este marco lo que tiene que
hacer es reconocer me gustaría que
nuestra contrincante diga cuánto vale
cuando va a devolver los millones de
soles que se llevan en el marco de la
corrupción hay una mucha injerencia en
el poder jugar en el poder judicial lo
que creemos importante que los jueces
deben ser electos por su entorno
abiertamente y que tengan la solvencia
moral y tiene que tener todo el respaldo
de la sociedad
empezamos por este espacio la población
conoce quién es quién pero haremos una
convocatoria a las personas que
necesitan limpiar el país para que no
estén todo el tiempo en el anonimato
hay gente que políticamente no quieren o
no quiere salir porque políticamente se
las mancha hemos encontrado muchos
profesionales que tienen libros que
tienen tomos históricos en el marco de
la corrupción en ese contexto creemos
importante manifestar las de que nuestra
lucha será frontal caiga quien caiga
venga de donde venga sea quien sea
gracias candidato ahora escucharemos la
segunda pregunta ciudadana
y
buenas noches mi nombre es hernán
lanzará y vivo en la ciudad de lynn mi
pregunta es la siguiente
en un evento al gobierno suyo como
fortalecería a la comisión de alto nivel
anticorrupción y a la autoridad nacional
de transparencia y acceso a la
información pública
[Música]
bueno
bien nuevamente el turno de intervención
se ha invertido e iniciaremos entonces
con la respuesta del candidato pedro
castillo de perú libre adelante señor
candidato sencillo sin coaccionar a las
autoridades respetando para que son
elegidos tenemos que implementar
cautelar también a ellos porque muchas
veces cuando se implementa no se se
quieren ordenar a las instituciones para
combatir la corrupción si las
autoridades mismas se ven amenazadas por
el poder político por el poder económico
entonces el gobierno tiene que tener la
prioridad de cautelar a las personas que
asumen esta responsabilidad porque la
corrupción
donde por todo lado
y para tener y para y un corrupto no
puede hablar de corrupción es como
soltar a un chivo que vaya a cuidar a
cuidar un jardín entonces lo que tenemos
que asumir en este marco la se
descentralice no solamente en clima los
problemas de corrupción sino en cada una
de las regiones porque los problemas las
entidades contra la corrupción en
algunas regiones hoy solamente sirven
como una mesa de partes tenemos que
hacer llegar el estado para luchar con
la corrupción a todos a todos los
extremos del país
gracias candidato pedro castillo de perú
libre ahora es el turno de la candidata
keiko fujimori de fuerza popular quien
también tiene un minuto con 30 segundos
para responder la consulta ciudadana
adelante candidata
por alusión voy a empezar a contestar al
contrincante
si se trata de hablar de solvencia moral
no lance usted piedras cuando tiene
tremendo techo de vidrio señor cerró
no se haga el muy machito que yo sé cómo
contestar también y sobre mis procesos
de investigación yo le puedo decir que
durante cinco años se me ha investigado
a mí ya mi familia y le puedo decir que
no uno no tres sino cinco peritos
contratados por el propio ministerio
público hicieron un análisis pericial de
diez años de nuestras finanzas y
contabilidad y que señalaron estos
peritos del ministerio público que en
nuestro caso no hay desbalance
patrimonial nosotros nunca hemos sido
gobierno como sí lo ha sido su padre
político el señor se ron sentenciado por
corrupción con referencia a la pregunta
ciudadana la comisión de alto nivel que
yo estoy proponiendo para luchar contra
este flagelo lo que nosotros queremos es
convocar a personas alejadas de la
política y si son críticos nuestros
mejor
porque eso ayudará a que constantemente
se fiscalicen nuestro futuro gobierno
ese es mi compromiso
agradecemos a ambos candidatos a la
presidencia por sus respuestas a los
ciudadanos ahora daremos pase a las
palabras de cierre por el espacio de 1
minuto en este caso debido a un sorteo
previo le toca iniciar al candidato
pedro castillo de perú libre adelante
candidato gracias al en esta noche
estamos al frente del perú dos líderes
uno del magisterio elegido por los
maestros aplaudido por el pueblo o los
padres de familias niños y otra
el jefe de una red criminal
elegida por oler es la propia confía en
su prensa por jorge barata
dionisio romero vito rodríguez en grupo
gloria y los que lo siguen si empiezo de
nuevo y empieza ahora a hablar de la
corrupción llegaría hasta el
bicentenario hablando todo este tema
muchas gracias
gracias candidato castillo damos el pase
entonces a la candidata keiko fujimori
de fuerza popular para su mensaje final
red criminal la de ustedes presidida por
el señor serrón que tiene condena
sentencia firme por corrupción
pero como lo dije desde el comienzo la
corrupción es un mal que afecta a todos
por igual la corrupción le hace daño a
los niños y hace daño a los ancianos le
hace daño a los enfermos es un mal
totalmente transversal es por eso que yo
quiero hacer un compromiso con todos los
peruanos mañana en la mañana aquí en
arequipa ciudad de grandes gestas
democráticas con la presencia del doctor
mario vargas llosa desde españa vía
digital
con las que y otras personas con las que
no he coincidido políticamente celebraré
un juramento por el perú un juramento de
compromiso de lucha contra la corrupción
de defensa de la democracia
gracias candidata keiko fujimori quiero
recordar a ambos candidatos que la
intención de esta cita es el debate de
las propuestas e ideas para que la
ciudadanía pueda escoger la que
considere mejor hacemos una nueva pausa
comercial y regresamos con el sexto y
último bloque que tratará de derechos
humanos políticas sociales y atención a
poblaciones en situación de
vulnerabilidad
cierre del quinto tema de este debate
presidencial en perú lucha contra la
corrupción e integridad pública muchos
puntos de vista distintos y en este
punto creo que coincide no sé qué
piensan mauricio sabaleta uno de
nuestros invitados si aquí ya hubo un
poco más de confrontación entre los dos
candidatos
en torno a diferentes casos de
corrupción que han salpicado a las
formaciones políticas o incluso a los
mismos candidatos ya sabemos el tema del
caso de 'break' que ha sido investigado
allí en perú y que ha salpicado
precisamente a keiko fujimori y mauricio
adelante sus impresiones sobre este tema
de corrupción y también le invito para
que haga una pequeña reflexión y
conclusión sobre el tema 4 que estaba
pendiente
perfecto en realidad efectivamente
coincido contigo santiago en que en
realidad es donde hemos visto mayor
confrontación ha sido dentro de todo el
espacio un poco más entretenido dentro
de un debate
bastante soporífero en realidad con
pocas propuestas con poca habilidad
política que hemos visto a pedro
castillo directamente atacando a la
señora fujimori y viceversa el ataque de
keiko fujimori viene desde la dimisión
para primer nos están viendo fuera del
perú él es el líder del partido del
pedro castillo ha sido el gobernador
regional de una región llamada junín y
que ha sido condenado por corrupción
entonces ella ha tratado de vincular
directamente a castillo con cerrón y él
ha tratado más bien de él
digamos distanciarse y por el otro lado
keiko fujimori es la heredera política
del fujimorato del periodo durante la
década de los 90 que gobernó alberto
fujimori en perú y que cae en medio de
un gran escándalo de corrupción en el
cual el poderoso asesor presidencial
vladimiro montesinos entregaba una
a un congresista para pasarse al
oficialismo entonces ambos han tratado
de explotar esos déficits que tienen
cada uno en relación a la materia de
propuesta también nos hemos quedado
bastante cortos verdad
keiko fujimori propone una comisión de
alto nivel pedro castillo propone una
comisión parecida
y el de keiko fujimori se integrada por
gente de la sociedad civil gente no
vinculada a lo político mientras pedro
castillo habla de autoridades autónomas
pero más allá de eso que hacer sobre la
corrupción también nos hemos quedado
bastante cortos como ciudadanos bien que
es lo que hay que hacer de manera
efectiva y nuevamente vuelvo a reiterar
estamos en un debate donde no tenemos
los ciudadanos del perú
mayor idea de cómo van a implementar sus
propuestas
que coincidieron estos dos candidatos en
fortalecer la contraloría para que
investigue en casos de corrupción para
que tenga un poco más de poder y acción
a la hora de investigar y tengo mejor
presupuesto pero cómo hacer esto cuando
precisamente una de las críticas
ciudadanas es la falta de confianza en
la institucionalidad y en algunas
instituciones del estado peruano como
por ejemplo la contraloría
la contraloría es una de las
instituciones que tienen un poco más de
confianza de los ciudadanos el problema
es que es esa receta que ha dado a todos
candidatos por dar mayor capacidad a la
contraloría es algo que han repetido
todos los candidatos durante la primera
vuelta pero no nos dicen qué facultad es
específicamente sancionadoras bueno pero
en qué instancias en qué momentos
debemos debe entrar la contraloría
control concurrente ok pero eso ya lo
viene realizando la contraloría tiene
bastante fuerza tiene capacidad
sancionadora realiza control concurrente
entonces no parecen estar haciendo nada
nuevo a lo que ya realmente ocurre
perfecto mauricio conectamos de nuevo
con la señal de tv perú la televisión
pública peruana y este debate que tiene
lugar allí en la ciudad de arequipa en
el sur del país la ciudad blanca como es
denominada la ciudad de arequipa ya
comenzó el sexto tema que tiene que ver
con derechos humanos veamos
[Música]
bloques 6 derechos humanos políticas
sociales y atención a poblaciones
vulnerables entre el 2009 y 2019 la tasa
de población mayor de 14 años sin seguro
de pensión ha disminuido en cinco puntos
porcentuales de 75.2 por ciento al 69
puntos 6% es decir al 2019 siete de cada
diez peruanos mayores de 14 años de edad
no tienen seguro de pensión en cuanto al
tema de vivienda entre el 2007 y 2017 ha
habido un avance de 12 puntos hacia la
reducción de la proporción de hogares
con viviendas sin acceso a servicios
higiénicos que pasó del 17.2 por ciento
al 5.8 por ciento es decir 1 de cada 20
hogares peruanos no dispone de servicios
higiénicos por otro lado se ha
demostrado que el hacinamiento en los
hogares supone un factor de riesgo en el
puntaje del cob y 19 entre 2007 y 2017
la tasa de hogares en condiciones de
hacinamiento se ha reducido de un 20 por
ciento a un 11.9 por ciento es decir 1
de cada 10 peruanos aún viven en una
vivienda
ción del cimiento
[Música]
al igual que en los bloques anteriores
en esta oportunidad cada candidato
cuenta con 3 minutos para exponer damos
inicio con la candidata keiko fujimori
de fuerza popular adelante candidata
en los últimos años los últimos
gobiernos lamentablemente han hecho muy
poco por nuestra sociedad y sobre todo
por la población más vulnerable todos
queremos un cambio
y un cambio hacia adelante un cambio que
nos devuelve a la confianza
que nos dé un gobierno con capacidad de
gestión que cumpla con la palabra que sí
nos ofrece una obra ésta se realiza
esta pandemia nos ha hecho retroceder 10
años
la pobreza se ha incrementado en un 10%
ha pasado del 20 al 30% y esto es
realmente terrible profundamente
doloroso para nuestro país
y por eso es que tenemos que implementar
una serie de programas sociales para
ayudar a las personas más necesitadas
he anunciado que mientras haremos los 3
millones de conexiones de agua y
saneamiento lanzaremos el problema el
programa agua para ti hemos anunciado la
entrega de 2 millones de títulos de
propiedad pero también tenemos que
potenciar el programa pronaa vamos a
triplicar su presupuesto para trabajar
directamente con las dirigentas de los
comedores populares los clubes de madres
del vaso de leche ya incluiremos a las
mamitas de las ollas comunes que durante
todos estos meses
han tenido que tocar muchas puertas para
poder ayudar a sus familias ya sus
vecinos y el estado nuevamente miro de
costado
vamos a potenciar otros programas no
importa quien los haya creado lo
importante es que funcionen y hemos
dicho pensión 65 haremos dos cambios en
primer lugar se aumentará el primer día
de mi gobierno se va a duplicar la
pensión de 250 a 500 soles mensuales
para todos los adultos mayores esa
población vulnerable que está abandonada
pero no solamente eso en estos momentos
son 560 mil personas las que reciben
este beneficio cada año de mi gobierno
aumentaremos 500 mil beneficiarios más
para lograr la pensión universal que
tanto anhelamos el programa juntos vamos
a aumentar de 200 soles a 300 soles
mensuales
de esta manera llegaremos a la población
tan olvidada
gracias candidata keiko fujimori a
continuación por tres minutos igualmente
sobre el mismo tema escucharemos las
propuestas del candidato pedro castillo
de perú libre adelante señor candidato
muchas gracias el perú
no puede volver al pasado
los derechos humanos
son derechos sin ningún tipo de
discriminación en nuestro gobierno no
habrán dictaduras
en todos los pueblos existen ancianos
abandonados existen ciudadanos sin dni
existen jóvenes abandonados sin opciones
a salir adelante familias frustradas
niños que no tienen ni padre ni madre
miles de niños que no tienen hoy en este
momento en pleno siglo en pleno siglo 21
de cara al bicentenario hay niños que no
conocen la escuela niños analfabetos que
nosotros lo conocemos en todas las
regiones del país
y hogares que no tienen los servicios
básicos
como es posible que tengamos
funcionarios con sueldos jugosos
congresistas que han ocupado muchísimas
curules por décadas ahí no andan ni
siquiera se atreven a hacer una reunión
arriba en la punta del cerro para ver su
prioridad
queremos importante manifestar las de
que estos derechos no es llevarles por
este deporte por un período de gobierno
llevarles una migaja quisiéramos que
estas personas participen abiertamente
en la nube en la gesta de una nueva
constitución para terminar con todas
estas desigualdades los derechos los
derechos humanos tiene que ser una
prioridad porque no podemos nosotros en
un país tan rico
hacer este tipo de discriminaciones
juntamente con ellos creemos importante
manifestarles de que haremos una lucha
en todos los rincones del país que así
como los fenómenos naturales golpean a
la naturaleza a los pueblos el problema
de figura que es un problema en la
recuperación del norte de ica la
recuperación del sur que siguen con
problemas no solamente de salud no
solamente vivienda no se puede politizar
un derecho constitucional el derecho no
se puede traficar con el hambre no se
puede traficar políticamente con la
salud del pueblo no se puede fraccionar
te doy algunos cuantos si no eres santo
de mi devoción y si no votas te por mí
no te doy nada no es así los derechos
son derechos y por eso es obligación de
todos los estamentos del estado y como
gobierno hacer una cruzada nacional en
igualdad de oportunidades por eso es que
se clama que una próxima constitución
y nadie se queda en nuestro gobierno
nadie se queda atrás
gracias candidato pedro castillo muy
bien entonces ahora damos pase al
momento de diálogo o interacción entre
los candidatos recordarles que cada uno
de ustedes cuenta con cuatro minutos
para que puedan administrarlo les parece
si empezamos hablando sobre las
políticas públicas que plantean para la
prevención de la violencia de género
contra las mujeres y niñas algunos de
ustedes desea iniciar
candidato pedro castillo adelante si lo
primero que tiene que hacer es concebir
la persona tiene que saber qué cosa es
un derecho
un derecho es algo innato es algo que se
exige pero el derecho no puede ir
separado no puede ir aislado el derecho
tiene que ir con el deber
creemos importante que es el deber es la
responsabilidad del estado asumir para
que no haya ningún disco y ningún tipo
de discriminación de género de raza ni
color de piel ni de religión ni de
pensamiento entonces yo concibo por
ejemplo que esta constitución que se ha
hecho que primero concibe en un primer
capítulo los derechos y deberes de las
personas su modelo económico que es
inherente a la gran corrupción y la
estructura del estado
el estado está estructurado para los de
arriba no para los de abajo yo recorrió
el país y sigo recorriendo el país y
pregunte en cada plaza alguien ha sido
consultado para socializar la con la
constitución no porque se ha hecho en un
régimen dictatorial y en el marco de un
golpe de estado y por eso es que no
concibe a la persona como ente
fundamental y se manosea políticamente
que te voy a dar esto entonces a la
persona como pues ser humano los
derechos sin igual condiciones
cualquiera sea su procedencia
candidata fujimori
si primero voy a contestar la pregunta
del moderador qué
nos preguntas sobre políticas públicas
de prevención contra el maltrato contra
la mujer primero es fundamental hacer un
llamado a todas las mujeres a no guardar
silencio a levantar nuestra voz sobre
todo frente al machismo
pero también es importante de parte del
estado crear casas refugios porque
cuando esto sucede ellas necesitan un
espacio donde protegerse donde estar y
dónde volver a empezar muchos de los
problemas que ocurren es que las mujeres
no tienen la oportunidad de tener
libertad económica y para ellas habrá
que capacitar las darles talleres y
darles un crédito especial pero a mí se
me hace muy extraño y contradictorio que
el señor castillo hable de derechos
humanos el que propone el cierre de la
defensoría del pueblo
el que propone el cierre del tribunal
constitucional
con qué autoridad viene a hablar de
derechos humanos si va a cerrar las
principales instituciones que se
encargan de defenderlo
habla luego de dictadura
creo que no escuchado el señor bermejo
que ellos plantean entrar al poder para
quedarse
usted ve los medios de comunicación
parece que no señor pedro tira piedras
deje de lanzar tantas mentiras el pueblo
está informado y nosotros queremos paz
ese es el segundo aspecto que voy a
tocar pero lo voy a dejar contestar
candidato castillo si las políticas
sociales hermano sexto tema y último
tema de este debate presidencial en perú
sobre derechos humanos atención a la
población vulnerable y políticas
sociales y estamos notando ahí un
rifirrafe entre los dos candidatos doy
paso entonces a los invitados que hemos
convocado para hacer el análisis para el
cierre ya de estos últimos minutos de
este especial de france 24 comienzo con
enzo su opinión general de este debate
para luego mirar por los temas
analizados a lo largo de la transmisión
adelante en su
bien a ver nos concentramos primero en
el objetivo del que se supone tenía este
debate que básicamente era generar
propuestas concretas en principio en
segundo lugar tener la oportunidad de
diferenciar la viabilidad de las mismas
entre un candidato y otro y ambos para
aclarar algunos temas que pudieron
quedar en entredicho a lo largo de la
campaña y derrotar también los temores
que se habían generado en torno a sus
propias campañas electorales
a la explicación del cómo iban a
realizar las propuestas iba a ser
trascendental porque por ejemplo nos
podía diferenciar entre una propuesta y
otra y esto podría incluso animar a los
indecisos dentro de la composición del
voto hay un voto sólido o duro que
tienen los candidatos y otra porción del
voto voluble que es aquel que por
emociones se puede cambiar o puede
finalmente desinteresarse de ambos
candidatos yo creo que no han apuntado a
ese tipo de público y han perdido una
gran oportunidad de marcar una gran
diferencia el tema de los ataques y los
puyazos genera una gran parte de esta
agenda creo que también se han distraído
mucho en ello han habido muchas falacias
argumentativas a la hora de generar el
debate ya veíamos anta en el cierre que
keiko por ejemplo atacaba y luego decía
hasta le puso el apodo de pedro tira
piedra y al final dice pero nosotros
queremos
entonces ni siquiera hay coherencia
digamos de las partes en el momento en
el propio momento de su expresión eso
solo para resumir en general han perdido
una gran oportunidad de poder finalmente
convencer a electorado indeciso
mauricio su opinión de este cierre del
debate
bueno en realidad me gustaría reseñar
brevemente las estrategias a mi modo de
ver de ambos candidatos la candidata
fujimori ha tenido una estrategia si se
quiere de segmentar su discurso ha
hablado para hacer dos segmentos de la
población que pueden ser claves y que se
han visto afectados por la pandemia ha
hablado de las amas de casa les ha dicho
que se va a encarecer el pan hablado de
la encarecimiento de los productos en
general ha hablado los pescadores
y ha hablado del sector turismo algo que
ya había mencionado en en la sección
anterior no pero ha tratado de dar
discursos sobre todo vinculados a el
bolsillo de las personas me parece que
es
es la estrategia general de la candidata
fujimori y por supuesto generando temor
respecto al candidato pedro castillo
es paradójico de alguna manera como
comentaba eso no termina diciendo no
tengas miedo pero ella es una de las
primeras impulsoras del miedo en el caso
pero castillo yo creo que hasta llega a
ser una falta de respeto su
improvisación frente al público no si es
que tiene una estrategia su estrategia
ha sido mencionar no hay estado donde
está el estado cuando se necesita el
estado no está porque hay funcionarios
corruptos que ganan grandes sueldos
y nosotros vamos a terminar con eso pero
no dando soluciones de política pública
no se le preguntó por ejemplo en este
último bloque sobre violencia contra la
mujer y no respondió nada respecto a eso
y ya haciendo un balance general son dos
candidatos que generan dudas frente a
los electores y dudas completamente
legítimas respecto a su compromiso con
la democracia no en el caso de keiko
fujimori creo que ha perdido la
oportunidad para dar confianza a ciertos
electores que podrían verla como un mal
menor comprometiéndose a respetar normas
comprometiéndose a la autonomía de los
poderes lo mencionado manera muy
superficial y en el caso de pedro
castillo también comprometiéndose a eso
y mostrando seriedad en su agenda de
gobierno eventualmente ganar ahí también
él tenía posibilidad de mostrarse como
anual menor y creo que no han terminado
aprovechando esas posibilidades para
desprenderse en las dudas que podrían
tener un elector indeciso
en estos 10 minutos que nos quedan de
análisis y mauricio enzo que leemos un
poco más fino en las ideas y lo que han
dicho los candidatos comienzo por enzo
alguna propuesta de cada uno de los dos
candidatos que usted considere que puede
ser como la propuesta de oro o la
propuesta destacada después de este
debate porque creo que los dos coinciden
en que hubo muchas ideas pero pocos
planes de como realizarlas entonces que
se puede destacar de los dos bailando un
poco más fino
bueno en principio cuando hablo de
economía que evidentemente es el fuerte
de keiko fujimori trató de concentrarse
en una variedad de propuestas en el tema
por ejemplo ya relacionado a la
educación creo que otro tema que destacó
es una alternativa concreta en relación
a cómo iba a cerrar esta brecha mes yo
me sigo quedando con que faltó generar
impacto por otro lado en el caso del
señor castillo la fortaleza o una de las
fortalezas principales cuando se refirió
por lo menos por el tema de la
corrupción habló que él personalmente se
iba a encargar de dirigir y dio a
entender el grupo digamos anticorrupción
otro tema de la educación también en
donde iba a cubrir a las falencias y que
hay tanto de maestros de alumnos intentó
mencionar de qué
cada alumno es un mundo diferente y por
ende iba a concentrarse en la estrategia
y personalizar un poco la educación y
las necesidades del educando esas pueden
ser las propuestas que ligeramente
pudieron destacar sin embargo siento
mucho vacío en las mismas tratando de
ser objetivos en este análisis
mauricio y su opinión alguna propuesta
de oro para destacar es que es bien
difícil hilar fino cuando no tenemos el
material para hacerlo yo lo que diría
que en general podríamos agrupar las
propuestas de keiko fujimori o la gran
propuesta que está tratando de vender a
los electores es que vamos a dar
incentivos para el trabajo y te vamos a
dar bonos que van desde aquellas
personas que han perdido a un familiar
debido a la comey 19
personas que están en zonas de
intervención minera a los agricultores
dijo en específico que se iba a pedir
una contribución voluntaria por parte de
la minera para establecer los hervores
de agua pero en realidad es una una
entrega de ciertos incentivos y sobre
todo un mercado libre de trabajo no creo
que ese es ese su gran propuesta si
podemos decirlo de esa manera si lo
podemos englobar no
en el caso digamos su gran discurso me
parece que es falta mercado si uno fue
estoy esté poniendo palabras en la boca
de keiko que ella no ha dicho pero sé
ese sería el mensaje y en palabras de
castillo podríamos decir falta estado no
el problema en realidad se genera en que
no está el estado donde están los niños
en las zonas rurales no está el estado
en el sistema de salud a mí me pareció
muy importante como en cuadro el sistema
de salud diciendo el sistema de salud no
ha colapsado con la pandemia
el sistema ya venía colapsado y
efectivamente era muy difícil conseguir
una cita en el en el seguro social o en
cualquiera de las dependencias que
brinda el servicio salud ya que tenemos
un sistema extremadamente fragmentado en
el perú entonces sí me parece que hay un
sentido de falta estado y yo quiero
garantizar estado para algunos
ciudadanos entonces me parece que esos
serían los dos grandes discursos de
estos candidatos rápidamente a los dos
les pregunto hay prácticamente un empate
técnico entre los dos candidatos creen
que
y la balanza se ha movido para alguno de
los dos lados después de este debate
mauricio
difícilmente me parece que ninguno como
decía anteriormente ha aprovechado la
oportunidad sobre todo para desprenderse
de los miedos que
y algunos de ellos son absolutamente
legítimos tenemos dos candidatos que
generan enormes dudas respecto sobre
todo a su compromiso con la democracia
al principio de la primera vuelta pero
castilla decía que iba a desactivar el
tribunal constitucional y la defensoría
del pueblo
keiko fujimori anteriormente que ha
ejercido el poder como jefa de la
oposición en el gobierno pasado de
manera desleal había dicho que había que
denunciar el pacto de san josé entonces
estamos frente a candidatos que deberían
más bien generar confianza en la
ciudadanía y han desperdiciado su
oportunidad en su opinión en puntual por
favor porque quiero hacerles una última
pregunta me quedan pocos minutos se
movió la balanza para algún lado el
censo no para nada
coincido coincido con el señor zabaleta
de ninguna manera no han hecho a nada
impresionante ni nada convincente y todo
el mundo lo esperaba y no nos llenaron
ese vacío
bueno ahora les hago la pregunta de oro
para el cierre y la gran conclusión de
este debate comienzo por enzo aquí si le
puedo dar un poco más de minutos para
que responda quien ganó este debate
bueno a ver es difícil pregunta porque
como ambos candidatos no han llenado ni
han superado las expectativas que como
que morí pudo lucirse un poco más así
que no creo que ella haya sido la
ganadora
respecto del señor castillo y creo que
podría haber ganado parcialmente si es
que en aquel electorado que tenía miedo
en relación a determinadas propuestas
pues parte de sus discursos o de su
mensaje que no va a expropiar que no va
a ser el el perú un destino o un país de
modelo chavista etcétera que no está
relacionado al terrorismo todas todas
aquellos aspectos en los que de hecho
creo que le faltó contundencia en la
medida en que por lo menos alguna parte
del electorado así haya dejado convencer
por esas afirmaciones podría sumársele
acaso algunas décimas de un punto
porcentual
dentro de su preferencia electoral
quizás por allí él haya tenido ese tipo
de ventaja porque lo que tenía que hacer
en este debate como una estrategia era
aclarar aquellas dudas aclarar aquellos
miedos creo que algunos los ha podido
aclarar pero que le ha faltado
convicción en otros como por ejemplo le
faltó quizás profundizar un poco más en
el tema del terrorismo o profundizar hay
pruebas de pronto con otro tipo de
argumentos creo igual me quedo con que
ligera o parcialmente pusiera lástima o
vicioso traducción quien ganó 40
segundos ya estamos como en el debate
presidencial es la pregunta más difícil
de responder y yo te voy a dar la
respuesta parecida a la de eso es muy
complicado determinar yo lo que creo es
que han hablado para quienes ya están
convencidos de votar por ellos por más
de que tenemos un sector importante de
y ciudadanos que todavía no hemos
decidido nuestro voto entonces qué y
cómo plantea una estrategia mucho más
pragmática y castillo plantea una idea
general entonces veamos qué va a ganar
el pragmatismo o una idea más grande de
necesitamos estado y tenemos que cambiar
la situación
mauricio sabaletas desde la ciudad de
charlotte en eeuu y enzo helguera en la
ciudad de lima la capital de perú
también estuvo al principio esta
transmisión francisco zacarías nuestro
corresponsal allí en la capital peruana
quiero agradecerles por haber estado con
nosotros haciendo el análisis de este
debate precio presidencial ustedes
también muchas gracias por la sintonía
sigan con france24